as reminded by my clerk I'm going to
read the
script all right so as chairman of the
house Edna
committee I find that due to state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the co9 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
personent to executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is the public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today an executive session
may be held on any Bill referred to the
committee please note there's no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform the public has access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n. Us in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote we'll start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member saids their presence please
also sayate whether there is anyone in
the room with you during the meeting
which is required under the right to
know
represent representative bro
president pres the committee is with me
representive Jayy pres in the committee
room representative
fellows um present home
alone uh representative haran showing in
for representative fno yes I'm repr
Horgan is here at my home in at my home
in Durham alone thank you repr
percentage of
here at home my wife is in the other
room
representative home here home in my
office alone representative
Judy I'm home and my wife she's in the
other Home representative
lar I'm here home um family is in the
home also representative leus I'm here
in the committee
room representative McGuire pres in the
committee room representative
O'Brian representative o'
Brian not present yet representative
Pearson representative Pearson is in the
committee room representative Roy has
sent word that he'll be a few minutes
late representative Sant
naso pres wait a
second uh as they come in you'll note
their presence representative
Schmidt cles are running late
representative show it present at my
home in
pmro representative
Schultz present at my resident and
conquered my husband Jean Taylor will be
in and out of the room okay uh Maguire
we have one two
three four
expected you did not call Representative
yakovich I did not call Representative
yakovich is he
here
okay uh zooming in the moment all right
we still have the four miss four not yet
president O'Brian Roy saso and
Schmid thank you representative
sh all right good morning we have our
first hearing is on House Bill
187 and I call Representative
Marsh to thank you madam chair can you
hear hear me yes very well uh very good
I I thank you and members of the
committee for the record I'm
representative William Marsh Carol
County 8 representing seven towns in
southern Caroll County and I am pleased
today to offer for your consideration
House Bill 187 relative to the emergency
powers of the Commissioner of Health and
Human Services as you all know this bill
passed HHS in elderly Affairs 19-2 and
the house
to6 uh this bill does not address the
governor's emergency orders other bills
do that this bill addresses emergency
orders from the commissioner of DHHS of
which there were two on April 3rd the
commissioner issued an emergency order
regarding the prescribing and
distribution of chloroquin to treat
covid-19 on September 1 she rescinded
that emergency order the bill also deals
with various powers under the public
health and infectious disease laws let
me go through the bill and hit the
highlights
page one lines 13 to 14 we strike in any
other law to the contrary the role
doctors and nurses played in the
Holocaust is troubling to me and I'm
troubled that emergency orders could in
New Hampshire supersede certain criminal
laws not that I believe our commissioner
would ever be involved in
such page one line 17 to 23 you can see
current law which I believe was
appropriately used to limit the
distribution of hydroxy chloroquin under
the emergency order
but I am not convinced the legislature
intended to give the power to the
commissioner to prevent the prescribing
of a drug medical professionals had
reason to believe might be effective
changing restrict to prioritize and
adding lines 24 to 25 clarify that we
are not granting that
power during Bill drafting the need for
input into the vaccine distribution plan
became evident reviewing the statute I
saw that we had an existing Ethics
Committee so I called John Williams and
asked who was on it he told me there
were no current appointees but the
governor subsequently reconstituted it
be ready for the next pandemic this is
referenced in lines 26 to 29 and we will
discuss that further in section two of
the
bill page two lines 16 to 17 we're
changing none of the language of the
existing statute but changing the
reference the language of the current
statute clearly states that an
individual May refuse treat treatment
but the current reference RSA 141 C15
Roman 6 States any law enforcement
officer shall take such individual into
custody and transport the individual to
the place of facility where the
treatment is to be
provided RSA 141 c16 clearly gives
individuals the right to refuse
treatment and remain in quarantine and I
believe that was what was intended the
second reference is the grounds for
refusing vaccination in current law
page two line 29 and on this new
language one of our objectives is to
make sure emergency orders are subject
to legislative oversight HHS oversight
already exists so we do not need to
create a committee for this Purpose with
the current membership of five a
two-thirds vote would be four out of
five members a very high
threshold HHS Nal Affairs felt this was
sufficiently high to prevent this
Authority from being
misused section two of the bill is a
rewrite of the Ethics Committee
established for H1N1 to accomplish five
things one the committee should actually
have appointees and exist when it is
needed by appointing legislators to the
committee we can make sure that will
happen two the committee should review
investigations orders and treatments
ordered to make sure they're done
appropriately and fairly this will be
done with Aggregate and deidentified
data three last year's HHS nly Affairs
committee was contacted by an individual
representing a disabled individual who
felt their rights were violated as a
mask order prevented them from getting
needed Medical Care they couldn't go to
the doctor to get a note to say they
didn't eat a mask to see the doctor we
discussed having a commission to address
such concerns but the existing Ethics
Committee already in statute seemed a
more logical
place four the governor used the state
disaster medical advisory committee to
reconstitute this committee to create
the vaccine distribution plan when the
plan was created there was no data to
suggest the current vaccines prevented
the spread of disease if there were it
would have been debatable whether the
vaccine should first be deployed to
protect the most vulnerable in society
or to interrupt the vectors that spread
disease five DHHS felt that police and
fire members of a prior incarnation of
that committee did not bring a lot to
the table and therefore they asked us to
remove them however the professional
firefighters want to be put back on the
ethics advisory oversight committee and
I am quite amend amendable to that
Amendment section three addresses the
membership changes to HHS oversight in
last year's hb1 1245 one of the Omnibus
bills on page
nine we do not believe that those
changes were intended to remove minority
party input from HHS oversight and this
section undos the UND do those
changes thank you and with that I'm
willing to take
questions
questions I just
have do we do we have his written
testimony yes I sent it to you all by
email to make life easier for the clerk
I'm afraid I paraphrased a few sections
but it's close
enough thank you representative Marsh
the certainly makes your testimony more
effective are there any other questions
from the committee uh representative
SMI thank you madam chair uh good
morning representative Marsh good to see
you um um the first question I have is
with regard to the um the
appropriateness and the authority with
regard to the two-thirds vote um to
override uh
Commissioners um decisions
um as you probably know uh it's a
general rule of the legislature that no
committee has plary Authority um that um
that the legislature must uh weigh in on
um decisions uh recommendations off
offered by the all the Committees of the
of the legislature um I I I see you've
established a fairly High bar four out
of five
uh but
um I I'm still not completely
comfortable with the idea that we're
suddenly giving this committee um that
kind of authority can you speak to that
first Peter I think that you've been in
the house a lot longer than I have and
if you wish to change that to uh calling
a house session such the house will vote
on whether to uh resend the order I
would be perfectly amenable to that uh
uh but but I think some mechanism needs
to be in place such that there is
accountability right well I I I do agree
with you that that it's a Sticky
Wicket getting the legislature into this
kind of an emergency situation anyway
and that's my going to be my followup if
the chair will permit
um I think we representative schm I
think we've heard your question and the
sponsor has agreed with you that
something needs to be done in this
willing
accept well I I'm very comfortable with
that because I I've de dealt with
representative Marsh on a number of
issues over the years I have a lot of
confidence in his integrity and his
abilities uh and I do think that the
legislature needs to be involved more
than it is under the current statutes
with regard to emergencies I think some
of the proposed solutions that we've
seen in other bills uh go too far and
become effectively unworkable um
if you get the legislature into a
situation requiring immediate action or
effectively immediate action so uh we'll
we'll have a look at that representative
Marsh uh and I certainly do appreciate
your work on the bill thank
you representative site representative
where are
you where am I for the sake of the role
you didn't answer the Ro sorry sorry
thank thank you I I am indeed um present
uh in my usual circumstance uh at a
friend's house I am alone in the room at
the at the present time my friend may
come through at some point I'm sitting
in her kitchen um but I am otherwise
alone in
Portsmouth thank you any for
representative March yeah well Madam
chair may I just log in myself I think I
miss representative O'Brien I can
proceedings and I am alone and I'm in
nashwa thank you thank you
representative so again are there any
other questions for representative
Marsh all right seeing none thank you
I'd
like representative Max Abramson who
signed up to speak on this
[Music]
bill
I believe you're cleared to speak
representative ab and make sure you're
unmuted
while we're waiting for him I see
representative Santo naso is
here would you unmute please and Thomas
where you
are yeah I'm here in uh Peterboro New
Hampshire I'll be by myself say thank
you that Lees just representative Roy
moment
all right
repres you're you're recognized please
proceed all right it just accepted me
into the meeting just now um I so I'm
not going to repeat anything that the
sponsor already said uh I do support the
bill uh I'm representative Max Abramson
representing Hampton Hampton Falls and
seab
Brook um I do support the bill um but I
also uh agree with a comment earlier by
representative Schmidt um I did not want
to have um if the governor or the
commissioner of DHHS calls an emergency
or uh declares an order I believe they
need to do that immediately when there's
an iMed emergency um I would rather they
overreact until there's time for things
to kind of settle down we certainly had
a state of emergency uh back in March of
last year um but it's difficult
especially when you have a legislature
of 400 members of the house and 24
members of the Senate it's difficult for
all of us to meet and especially under
conditions like this um where just the
active meeting um creates the risk of
spreading uh a virus or or another type
of illness we don't we don't know what's
going to happen in the future um so my
uh my preference is to Simply have have
a provision where the commissioner of
DHHS can act and the governor can act
but have a a different mechanism in
place um where for example 100 members
of the house or 100 members of the
legislature are able to raise an
objection to a particular order and that
the um where we don't actually have to
meet in order to raise that objection
either by having the house clerk contact
each each member by email and uh respond
so if a particular uh emergency order is
a little too restrictive or Draconian or
in some cases if members feel that
they're counterproductive uh 100 members
would also be a pretty high bar and I'm
willing to to um draft that Amendment um
I also I I do understand that getting
four out of five on this particular
committee is is also High bar but that
that committee would actually have to
meet also um probably by Zoom session um
and it would
be um it it's very difficult to get um
how do you put this it's hard to
negotiate um from the vantage point of a
committee when you're negotiating it's
always one person versus another um and
when we have uh uh uh the executive
branches trying to be a bit too
restrictive our job is to serve as a a
check on the uh the power of the other
branches of government uh especially the
executive branch and I think that a
mechanism more like um Simply Having say
a 100 members raise an objection to a
particular restriction or uh an edict
coming down um and then having the
commissioner of the Department of of
Health and Human Services contact
individual members find out what their
concern is and then uh respond to that
and rewrite the order uh and as usual
I'm willing to do the footwork on that I
do support the rest of this bill I think
I I voted for it on the floor and I I
agree with the uh with uh the intent of
it thank you representative abson are
there any questions for him
representative Pearson thank you mam
chair thank you representative
Abramson for taking my
question
what we're talking about here
specifically is is a an act by the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services that as we've just been alluded
to by the prime sponsor here is um is
something that was done just
once with the actions of the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services are generally done because it
involves a technical
expertise that is above and beyond what
you would normally find specifically in
the executive Branch so representative
Abramson the the fact that this is this
is a legis according at least on page
two the the bottom part this is a joint
legislative oversight
committee that is that is made up of
people from Health and Human Services
that it would be fair to presume have
that level of
expertise do you
see do you not see this as as an
appropriate Avenue whereas the whole
house would conceivably lack that level
of expertise to to make a decision in
that in the manner in which you're
you're
advocating of of having a certain number
of members raising an
objection specifically just the fact
that you know the the purpose of the
joint legislative committee on Health
and Human Services is to provide
oversight but with the technical
background necessary to make that
oversight value have value and it'd be
legitimate um I understand where you're
coming from the particular type of
objection um that I would I would see
our role as raising is less about having
expertise about a particular subject
than um certain
obvious um instances I hate to bring up
U examples because some of them sound a
little bit silly I was contacted by my
local American Legion um and they said
they're allowed to open but they can't
do shuffle board and I said what you
know are you sure about that and they
said yeah they they've been contacted
would you do would you do something
about that and I'm not able to contact
the governor's office over letting the
American Legion open shuffle board
because I have a a liazon i I contact
who hasn't gotten back with
me if you if you would notice this bill
is about the orders of the
DHHS commissioner it is not about the
governor's orders we have other bills
we're dealing with on that these are
specifically HHS
orders and as was mentioned there was
exactly one a technical one restricting
the use of a medicine that was believed
to be in short
supply the the orders you're talking
about were the governor's executive
orders and they're not the subject of
this particular
uh I'm I'm I'm aware of that but there
there have been so many different um
restrictions and orders that have come
down when you have um when you have a
particular case um where one of your
constituents raises an objection and
it's raises an issue where it's
something is going to cause a health
problem or a hardship or is going to
cause a problem for that specific case
um whether it's because they're a
American Indian and their immune system
responds differently or they've had
prior medical problems um and they bring
it up with you and it's it's obvious
with just a constituent talking to you I
don't think that there's any particular
need for expertise when their doctors
has told them that there's a problem
with a particular order that that that's
the point where you as a member should
should raise an objection and whether
they've hit some mark 100 or not that
that the commission of DHHS should be
responding to that not not not pushing
down and then enforcing them where it's
going to create either an economic
hardship or it's going to create uh uh a
shortage somewhere in the marketplace or
it's going to create an issue um because
we can't meet in the middle of uh an
emergency and introduce a bill and have
that
bill take effect the executive branch
has to be able to respond to emergencies
and at the same time if they're over
responding or they're doing something
that's causing a problem with any one of
our constituents any of us needs to be
to serve as the messenger and say this
is an obvious case where a particular
restriction or requirement or rule that
you put in place is causing a hardship
for an individual or or potentially
health
problems thank
you representative
Schmid thank you madam chair uh so
representative aberson uh I I very much
appreciate the general uh seriousness
and uh um and rationality of your
general remarks uh because I I think
that it's clear that in a medical
emergency uh you have to have a rapid
response capability uh so the the the
question of what kind of an oversight
board or committee can be set up uh
frankly I don't like the idea of 100
legislators because you're talking about
people who potentially have no expertise
whatsoever being involved they might not
make up the majority uh but I think that
that the makeup of any oversight
committee that can review a
policy um is is something that we have
to entertain very seriously uh I I I I
am wondering whether uh you you'd care
to think further on this issue because
uh I I I think that it's clear that
there are some aspects the chair has
already talked about going a field uh
with regard to things not involving the
HHS
responsibility uh and that's appropriate
but if I may just IND if she'll indulge
me just a little bit we we had the
situation where the governor disregarded
the the recommendations of the joint
fiscal committee uh he had established
this goer uh entity which was completely
subject to his authority and and you
recall that he was sued by the
legislature by the fiscal committee and
the courts really did not want to get
into that if at all possible that's the
kind of thing we want to
avoid thank you representative Schmidt
but I would hope you would keep your
comments to the bill in question you can
be more broad ranging an executive
session but this is a hearing are there
any other people that wish members of
the committee that have questions for
representative
Abramson
fellows thank you madam chair I I just
would like to get um representative
Abrams
perspective so he can help me understand
the committee because the committee the
part of the bill that amends who's in
that committee and and what they you
know need to look into is more broad
than just emergency situations it adds
that but the the committee um has been
in existence for quite a while and I'm
just wondering if
it's really opening
up the door
for the um situation that he started to
explain about just constituents having
issues with all sorts of things and that
this committee will need
to address a lot of things other than
just executive order related things just
policies
that they don't um like that may impact
like people with disabilities for
example and those could those could be
executive orders doesn't have to be
executive order by the Health and Human
Service
um person um
commissioner so I'm just wondering what
what might be the implications of that
broadening the scope of that committee
and putting a lot more people on it
thank
you would you be able to answer this
question I think it's more in your scope
since you wrote the
Bill uh yes I'm still here and I'd be
glad to answer the question I don't
think we actually are broadening the
scope of Health and Human Services
oversight because we're really uh just
returning the house membership back to
what it was prior to the bill that was
signed into law this last summer uh for
instance I'm currently Vice chair of HHS
nly Affairs and the vice chair of HHS
nly Affairs has typically been on that
committee but I am not because there
aren't enough spots um and in general
the people who are appointed to HHS
oversight do have some expertise in
health care so if you're going to pick a
group out of the legislature uh to have
oversight over the the uh uh
major orders uh like the hydroxy
chloroquin order it's a good group to
pick for that the area where you really
need expertise are the various orders
that come out of the the uh infectious
disease laws and those are referred to
the uh the the second committee the uh
uh currently known as the E Ethics
Committee but we're renaming it the
ethics oversight committee um and those
people have pretty much been picked for
technical expertise and and are
appropriate for looking at those sorts
of questions
thank
you representative
hor I'm know whether this question is
more appropriately directed rent AB than
rent Marsh but um doesn't HHS in
addition to the emergency order on April
3rd about the medication they you know
issue lots of they make lots of policies
for all the different entities they deal
with remember we had a specific issue
with h nursing homes because my mother's
in well she's an assisted living
facility which is kind of an here sorry
could you speak more clearly I can't
understand a word you're saying oh sorry
yes um and I'm not even in the room okay
so I would we mentioned um an emergency
order that the commissioner um issued
but also the commissioner the uh
commissioner also issues all kinds of
other uh all kinds of other
Communications to various uh various
entities and um How would how would it
affect their ability to issue and U you
know carry out those I been WR a
specific issue my family my mother's in
a assisted living facility which
basically a nursing home and they had to
uh sent out a memo about nursing home um
at people moving in during covid which
was a misunderstooding and of course I'm
a State Rep so I probably more access to
the commissioner office I did but I
actually called them up and you know a
few minutes later got a call from a got
a call from one of the Commissioners
assistants and they actually were were
quite responsive to this and that's
some so this interfere with the uh
commissioner's you know existing ability
to you know uh deal with pandemic or
other
crises no I would say just the opposite
um and and through either way either
using this existing committee or having
100 members object or any number of
members object um and the reason is that
most of the time in my experience when
I've contacted do or Department of
Safety or another agency doing
constituent work um most of the time
they're responsive um but other than the
budget uh we don't have any mechanism in
place to kind of force them to be
responsive to the legislature
so sorry we don't have a mechanism to
force them to so if you had um let's say
50 members of the House object or or it
Rose to 60 that would be really unusual
circumstance um because an agency is not
being responsive then U they would
realize that that there's the potential
for them to be overridden by 100
objectors and uh U they would have to
take some kind of action they would have
to respond to the concerns of at least
some of them um and and for example in
your case um you happen to note um
people in the nursing home and people
who work at the nursing home
um who are in your District um almost
everyone in the state knows at least one
member of the house um and we we're very
fortunate to have some of the best
representation anywhere in the New
Hampshire state house and but if
somebody has a very specific problem
that's an obvious problem then they need
to be able to to contact their member of
the House and if it's if it's you know
potentially life-threatening then then
members of the House Can Talk Amongst
each other as as we we do both in
hearings and uh
you know we as we tend to socialize and
if enough of us raise an objection to a
specific order they should change that
order to uh uh accommodate the concern I
think it's a it it's much quicker than
trying to schedule a
meeting um of a committee or task force
or the legislature and try and have the
legislature take some kind of official
action thank you representative broa you
had a
question
you're
muted you have to unmute yourself
representative
for I'm so sorry apologies thank you
Madame chair representative Marsh is
chrisan is you do the these groups that
you're mentioned in your um in your bill
already exists right we're not forming
anything new we're just
putting we may be renaming something but
we're really not changing anything
that's being practiced now correct well
sort of HHS oversight exists and has
existed for a very long time uh the
Ethics Committee was in statute but no
one was appointed to it and that turned
out to be a problem when we wanted to
ask them to draft the vaccine
distribution plan so in fact it is a
change in that we are going to actually
make sure that this committee actually
exists rather than just being in statute
and having no one appointed to it follow
up please Madam
chair Madam chair follow up thank you um
so let me rephrase my question so
essentially in statute these groups
exist whether or not people were
appointed to them that's a different
issue yes okay thank you that my
question has been answered thank you
other
questions all right is there anyone else
who would wish to testify on House Bill
187 seeing none thank you very much I'm
going to close the public
hearing question mam chair yes um how do
you want to address the
amendment the
amendment do that EX
got I think we not quite we've only got
five minutes oh okay got however you do
you do have a motion on another bill 414
I do have a motion on
414 I'm gonna make the motion to retain
House Bill
414 is there a
second that's evacuation
order yes oh sorry
okay so we have a motion by
representative Pearson seconded by
representative leus to retain House Bill
414 and represent
Pearson in uh in a review of of one
thing in particular in New Hampshire
that would be substantially problematic
with 414 is that it it is um it is
completely and totally incompatible with
the cook emergency U plan that exists
not only from a New Hampshire standpoint
but for the regional uh plan that is
developed and required by the nuclear
Regulatory
Commission so I we're going to have to
uh we're GNA have to take that into
consideration here and figure out if if
414 is going to even be possible to jive
with with that particular New Hampshire
situation representative
laus
discuss is there anyone who has anything
any other comments on house build
414 seeing none the motion is to retain
and the CL call the
RO representative Roy yes cour VES yes
representative Pearson yes
representative jaage
yes Le representative Alro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Lara yes representative
saso yes representative goie yes
representative
sh yes representative
JY representative Schmid yes
representative schz
representative Schultz going once
twice yes there she is okay
representative
fellows yes representative Horan
yes representative R
yes representative O'Brien yes the chair
yes than
motion
passes assign that to a a committee for
for
work that already
clean yes representative
schm com no I'm
good glad to
hear I switched microphone pH is this
better yes yes thank you sorry about
that still have a few minutes but I
don't think any of the other bills we
have on tap are going to be that
easy or that quick sorry
quick
that's
[Music]
still should
should
br
all
is this conversation something that
we're supposed to be able to hear if
it's just cross
do
no no I was just mentioning to
representative Roy that representative
Sant naso is likely to lose connectivity
for a while and I was just reassuring
him that I'm not expecting to exec
anything until after lunch because we
have a public hearing to
do that's fine it's just if it was
intended to be audible I mean to be
intelligible to all of us that was not
happening and if it wasn't uh that's
okay
too well it wasn't secret but it wasn't
necessarily
A an announcement to the entire
committee that's fine I I was commenting
about the audio more than anything
else it's tough when we use our indoor
voices it really is Right which one is
next which bill is
next 533 5:33 and 1
minute what are
[Applause]
youing
probably being 10:45 I'm opening the
public hearing on housei 530 33 I call
Representative
Bry thank thank you madam chair um for
the record State red P bramy Rockingham
19 stratum excuse me fairly inaudible
could you speak a little more clearly
and
louder I have this problem once in a
while with my machine
here uh thank you madam chair uh State
for the record can you hear me better
not much
no think this is about as good as it's
going to get wait a minute give me one
second speak louder that always helps I
will speak as loud as I can he's a the
zoom participants Madam chair
but I'm sorry representative organ he's
really he's fairly clearly audible to me
as a zoom participants but obviously if
you're doing the people in the room the
technical there's more technical things
that can go wrong so yeah thank you that
may have been what happened to me
earlier so I apologize thanks
okay Madam chair I'll I'll I'll speak as
loud as I can here uh uh thank you first
uh for for allowing me to testify uh for
the record State Rep pamy Rockingham 19
stratum I'm here to introduce House Bill
533 establishing a division of
investigation and compliance in the
Lottery
Commission the I'm here as the prime
sponsor but also here representing the
whole of ways and means
I filed this bill at the request of
Charlie McIntyre the executive director
of
Lottery the bill does three major things
there's really four components to the
bill the first thing it does is
informally creates a division of
investigation and compliance within the
Lottery
Commission the bill creates a structure
only to be staffed by existing staff
members they are not asking for new
positions or
new
titles within the
bill in doing so it clearly outlines the
duties of investigation and compliance
again much of which is going on
today the second thing it does it
changes the way in which Lottery
interacts with the AG's office when it
comes to background checks required for
licenses in short Lottery require uh lot
will do a lot of the B the data
Gathering as it works with the AG but
the AG's office still has the final say
on the fitness of an applicant to
receive a
license the reason for this is it speeds
up licensing since fact finding will be
be a priority to the lottery and May at
times not be a priority to the AG's
office the third thing it does this bill
does is it gives the investigation and
enforcement division rulemaking
Authority and the the only other thing
is that it's effect the effective data
January 1
2022 Ways and Means voted uh we were the
we were the uh original committee on
this bill the policy committee on the
bill and it was voted out 22 nothing on
a bipartisan autopass
vote uh and wand up on on the consent
calendar what Ma and mean saw was the
lottery has grown
significantly with the Advent of Kino
sports betting and the growth in
charitable
gaming the functions of investigation
and compliance have always been
extremely important we concluded that an
organizational structure that reflects
this is is is much
needed that is my testimony Madam chair
I will take
questions I did talk to Charlie McIntyre
this morning and he has a conflict and
he cannot be
here but uh his chief compliance officer
John
coni is supposedly on the zoom I can't I
can't see that from here but if you can
let me know if he's on on the zoom I may
defer some of the questions to him thank
you what was the name John
um c c m f o r t he's here we promoted
him to panelist does he need to testify
or she just answer
questions so I'm willing to take
questions and uh again I filed this bill
on behalf of of Lottery and John may be
able to add uh some other reasoning
behind the lot's request for this but
I'll I'll take questions if if there are
any
representative
fellows I I did not mean to I don't
think I raised my hand okay no
problem Mr Cony do you have anything
that you need to say to us I can just
add uh representative abrami um gave a
great summary of the bill this is really
just a redefinition of the existing
structure this is not an addition of um
positions or titles
um at present um when we investigate new
um lenses for gaming uh all of the
responsibility goes to the Attorney
General's office um and so we do not
have authority to reach out to law
enforcement to gather information um and
as representative abrami said sometimes
um obviously the the Attorney General's
office has many uh roles and
responsibilities um gaming licensing is
not
highest on their priority list
understandably um and so ultimately this
bill allows us to do some of the leg
work on behalf of doj um as
representative abami said ultimately
they would still be responsible for
making a determination as to whether a
potential leny is fit to be involved
with gaming in New Hampshire but this
gives us some Authority on the front end
um at the Lottery Commission U to do
some of the background investig
package up that information and send it
to the Attorney General's office so that
we can make a decision together um and
hopefully expedite that process and also
we we obviously have uh sources of uh
information and intelligence that aren't
necessarily available to the attorney
jour's office they obviously have those
that are not available to us um so this
makes it more of a collaborative
investigation and oversight of our
charitable gaming which we believe is
important as representative abami said
this is a growing
uh area um and we want to make sure that
the people who are coming into this uh
gaming are uh are well suited to um to
work with Charities and to work with
players in the gaming
environment thank you uh representative
Shu thank you madam chair uh good
morning Mr Conforti uh I'm curious can
you tell us uh what kind of
qualifications investigators
for uh the Lottery Commission would have
as opposed to qualifications of uh
employees of the AG's office to do these
investigations so thank you for the
question representative um we the I I am
a former member of the Attorney
General's office so I I can speak to I
know that doj investigators are
generally former law enforcement um at
the Lottery Commission we have um five
investigator positions right now two are
former law enforcement uh officials um
who have come to us um one is a uh
former administrative investigator um
and two have been with the Lottery
Commission for so long I'm not sure what
their prior experience is but we do have
the head of our uh of our investigations
unit is a former law enforcement member
um and certainly future hiring we're
trying to stay in that in that
vein for question Madam chair follow up
thank you uh you also stated um that the
Lottery Commission has sources of
information not available to the AG
could you give us a little Enlightenment
as to what sources you
would sure I'd be happy to and I can use
a recent example um we have a lot of
information that you receive um comes
from other members of the Comm Community
um and so obviously we have a
relationship with all of our
lies um we have a very granular
understanding of what's happening in
these rooms um we have a relationship uh
with certain players in fact um that
that frequent these rooms so we had a
situation recently um that I I don't
want to go into depth in but we we had
received some information from other um
lenses that there may be areas of
concern with a leny um that wouldn't
have showed up on a uh criminal
background check or a financial record
check um and that's that's really what
I'm speaking to in terms of uh areas of
information that we get from being in
the in the field in the industry itself
that the Attorney General's office is
really doing highlevel criminal and
financial background checks um and
sometimes we can put puzzle pieces
together based on
information that we receive uh from our
lenses and from other people in the
gaming
industry thank you very much you
representative
goalie thank you madam chair uh just a
couple I think this needs a little word
smithing um looking at it I I think some
of the things that were're put in here
um need to be Rewritten if you look on
page
two uh line six and line seven it says
the Lottery Commission shall report the
results of s investigation to the
Attorney General within
45 and it strikes days after the receipt
of
request good point and also on the same
page line 10 and 11 um I think needs to
be fixed um it says discretion to
determine the extent of which in the
manner in which the results may be
reported to other state agency that
doesn't sound right I think it needs to
be
rewarded whether it's to the other state
agency or how we word it can be
determined and then one more spot uh
lines 12 to
13 um it ends with results are to retain
their confidential character ends in a
period and then on line 13 the Attorney
General should be start started with a
capital
T those are the changes I see that need
to be made thank you representative
goalie we make sure you get a chance to
review any
Amendment representative
O'Brian uh thank you madam chair and my
question uh Mr katti thank you for
taking my uh question uh I would imagine
if the the Attorney General's office
investigated me for such a position uh
everything would be uh confidential and
what I'm looking forward uh with you I
do see red line 12 and 13 of page two
but uh would you meet the current
standards by the AG's office and onon
conventionality of the
applicant that thank you representative
that would be my my expectation is that
that would be an investigation a
background investigation that would be
confidential whether it's done uh by the
uh Lottery Commission or the Attorney
General's office again this is not we we
are not taking over the investigation we
are just uh supplementing the
investigation that exists and I I it's
my belief that the confidential uh
manner of that would remain the
same thank you
m um representative broa
and thank you thank you when I read this
bill originally it sounded to me like it
was a result of self a self
audit and um I'm wondering would you
um is the Liquor Commission going to be
um be audited
soon just
was it was just it was
just I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't mean
the lottery Comm
sorry uh no trouble representative the
uh the lottery is is uh audited by LBA
every year um we just uh finished the
2000 the fiscal year 2020 audit um I'm
not sure if that's completely finalized
it should be very close to finalized um
I would say that our performance was was
very um very good um and actually none
of the findings that I believe relate to
the area of the commission that we're
discussing right now with regard to
charitable gaming um but yes uh we we
are still we are constantly uh looking
at ways to improve because we are as
representative abrami said we are
growing there's been additional um uh
games uh that have been authorized by
the legislature um and again we're
looking to improve processes uh I know
that there's a study commission that has
is under consideration by the
legislature right now which we um you
know we're looking forward to working
with if that does pass into law um but
we are constantly looking to improve our
processes uh and we're somewhat I don't
want to say forced into doing it but but
we we have to constantly evolve because
our games and our rooms are evolving um
Chara gaming is growing and so we're
trying to meet the the demands of the
increase in volume um that that has
occurred based on those those
changes thank you so much representative
Ramy yes uh thank you
um uh the uh I just want to say thank
you representative goalie for catching
those grammatical errors uh if you need
any assistance just let me know but I
think you got it covered interestingly
enough in my copy of the bill
I caught the first one and I think I was
supposed to say I think we caught it
late uh the the the 45 days with the
days
missing uh and I think I was supposed to
say can we do an amendment but in yourk
committee so it sounds like you got it
covered and uh if you need any help I'll
do it but it sounds like you guys you uh
I've got it
covered and something else and I can't
remember now but I'm fine thank you
representative
Roy thank you madam chair um my question
is for Mr coni um on page
two line 17 no excuse me 16 starting on
line 16 it says not withstanding any
other provision of law no person shall
be issued or hold the license if in the
opinion of the Attorney General such
person is not fit to be associated with
racing the state where attorney general
was um stricken previously is it
supposed could be remaining there that
it's up to the attorney general at the
end or is that something else you wanted
to change no that that should remain in
place um if you look at the way that
this is structured the Lottery
Commission shall
confer uh with the attorney general and
uh and ultimately the decision should be
um whether the Attorney General decides
that the person should be um associated
with racing again this was not a a um
attempt to take that decision-making
responsibility away from the Attorney
General's office it was a an attempt to
assist in the overall flow of these
investigations by taking some of the leg
work off of the
AG's office's plate um but ultimately we
our our uh intention was for the
Attorney General's office to
make the final determination on
suitability thank you followup yes thank
you madam chair um just if you could
real on the part where it says a person
is not fit can you explain to us if you
if you can just briefly um has that
standard been tested in an appeal or in
the courts not fit is there a definition
of not
fit there is not a there is not a formal
um definition of Fitness um and it is
somewhat subjective by Nature um
generally the what the attorney general
and other gaming um Regulators look at
is um criminal
convictions
associations um sources of money um and
whether those people are whether any of
those things indicate that somebody
lacks Trust trustworthiness um to be
associated with uh with with gaming and
in our state in particular with
charitable gaming um because these
people are not just um running um casino
games they're also acting as fiduciaries
for charitable funds that flow through
those rooms um so uh to my knowledge
representative that has not been tested
in uh an appeal um I am aware that um
we we've had a few people who have who
have not received licenses um in those
instances they've been for very sort of
bright line issues with respect to
criminal convictions um but those have
not been appeal to my to my knowledge
thank
you uh I have a question this maybe to
representative of Brony uh it keeps
saying associated with
racing is that the correct terminology
because the Lottery Commission is has a
great is responsible for a great deal
more things than just
race so
true Madam chair yes R Romy yeah you
know this this this all this whole bill
was
originally embedded in the historic
racing Bill uh that's uh that was just
passed in out of committee on ways and
means
uh but we decided to separate it out and
make it its own bill and that that is
the reason may have the racing focus on
it
uh it really is it really is really more
than just
racing uh it really is all of really all
of charitable gaming and and the rest of
Lottery good gaming or charitable gaming
or something like that be a better term
I I think so okay thank
you other
comments questions well I I have my hand
up as well so
yes uh yeah I remember the other other
thing um uh it was someone mentioned
about uh the fact that uh there's going
to be a joint committee review a meeting
meeting of House and Senate review of
char gaming that pass there's a house
version of the bill that did pass uh and
I think it was already on consent
calendar and there's a senate version my
understanding is going to is going to
pass as well we'll reconcile those where
we're going to take a top to bottom look
at charal gaming and ask all the tough
questions about where it is where it's
going so just that's going on in the
background just want to pass that along
thank
you thank
you are there any other questions for
representative of bromi
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
533 right seeing none close the public
hearing
I would I would say it's obvious this
bill needs a bit of fine-tuning at the
very least
uh representative goalie do you want to
take that on and come up with an
amendment for
us uh yes I can do that Madam chair
[Music]
I hope so yes and uh change racing Mayer
at it I I think gaming is more
appropriate because there's there's not
a whole lot of racing going
on I think gaming is Tech is aoad term
not
whatever gaming is what we're talking
about the most of it charitable but some
of it isn't what is charitable
G the lottery ticket is not
exactly mam chair
I'm I'm this is representative fellows
please
proceed um I'm just wondering if it's if
it says racing in there it might not
that might not even be the correct place
to put it in statute
if that's in a section that's just about
racing all right I
think very good representative goalie I
trust you'll have fun with that one I
will be doing a little research very
good yes if I may um I'm wondering since
representative abrami mentioned the uh
Joint Committee that's supposed to be
looking at these kinds of issues uh if
rather than the Standalone bill that has
this many
problems perhaps that joint committee
should really include this in their
studies and
conclusions that's something to
discuss um I think that the the
questions and issues appear to
be generally fairly minor Bo smithing as
representative goalie said rather
than the procedural point of the bill
namely to to establish a structure for
investigation we haven't heard anyone
saying there's any issues with that and
that's what the committee would look at
the word smithing is entirely separate
right and I understand that but uh
taking into account what representative
fellows said and representative bra
abami said that they were aiming this at
the historic racing which apparently is
going through but has not yet been fully
established so I don't think we want to
eliminate that portion from this and I
don't know do we need to
examine uh how to include both of those
issues in one
bill uh I believe that from what
representative bramy said that this had
been one bill and was this part was
split off except they didn't clean up
the language so uh we will be represent
B will be working on an amendment to
clean up the language and we will
consider this next week for scheduling
purposes we have hearings on Monday and
Wednesday next week the
24th and we should have time to uh exact
some of our other
bills on the on Monday the 22nd and
Wednesday the
24th representative
Schmid thank you madam chairman I might
point out that uh that so-called
historic racing actually is um is a slot
machine it's not it's not read rcing at
all um it's a slot machine so it it's it
doesn't belong under racing at all um
and so in addition to the colleagues
other remarks that that's something that
the committee needs to factor
in yes I agree but uh I think given the
grammar and Clarity issues that have
been brought up I'd like to wait for
further discussion until we have that
clean up document available oh yeah no
question about that
okay is there anything else that anyone
needs to bring to the committee's
[Music]
attention seeing none we will all have a
chance to get some exercise we're
resuming at
1:15 for the non- gerain amendment on
House Bill
can you mute
it oh
yeah
do you have
the
what
[Music]
sh
that's the oran
that's
Madam
chairman yes I think we're turned on we
are yeah you are um I just have a quick
question before you begin I I wonder if
you saw the email that I sent you at uh
lunchtime yes I did and I was looking
for those people on the uh in the
attendee list
okay well I see the one who wants to
speak
ah okay we'll move him up good I just
wanted to make sure
thanks here I see that some people are
listed as Edna I was myself earlier and
renamed myself but maybe that would be
helpful to those who are on here and
listed as Edna instead of their own
name well one of the labels of Edna is
the committee
room since we don't have a
bill let's see who the other one is
looks like representative Schmidt just
came in yeah that is a mysterious um
unexplained phenomenon we've had that
for weeks where people have come in as
as the committee name and I rename you
as quickly as I can and
um you know it's um it's yet to be
figured out why anybody because nobody
has sent a label of
Edna yes well it uh it's one of the M
it's probably a feature in Zoom that we
don't know about well I see two two
separate things that say Edna one is
committee room but the other one doesn't
have any picture or anything yes I think
it's the other computer that we thought
the clerk would be using a um a computer
so this morning the tech set up the
clerk work computer and for a while it
was just called chair that seemed
inappropriate so I called it Edna so the
two ednas are are really just computers
with no person near them and if any
others pop up I I hope to rename them
quickly I me the computer start talking
they will
be I was just thinking about that
memories of
2001 exactly all right it's 115
welcome to back to Edna we're having a
hearing on a non- gerain Amendment which
completely replaces the text of House
Bill 141 and I call Representative shu
to present her
Amendment thank you madam chair um with
the
um discussion that we had around House
Bill
141 and the fact that there were
apparent difficulties in that bill and
hoping that the committee sees fit to
dispense with that particular bill in
format I'm presenting the basic text the
exact text of House Bill
1561 from
2020 uh which is allowing a county to
exempt its chief administrative officer
from compulsory participation in the
retirement system
um I present this amendment particularly
at the request of our a hopeful new
administrative officer for Marat County
he has not accepted that title as yet in
hopes that this bill will be
passed because he uh currently has over
30 years in group two
retirement and if he accepted this
position as his full-time employment he
would have to go into group
one uh I see um Stuart Tracy who is one
of our marac County
Commissioners on the zoom and I assume
he's willing to
testify and explain um what that means
to this individual and how the County
Commissioners in maram County feel about
it the bill previously was presented on
beh half of a similar employee from
Sullivan County last
year and I will state that this
committee Edna passed that bill on a
vote of
16-2 and it later passed the house on
the consent
calendar however due to uh well as what
happened to many bills last year it died
a covid death when it arrived at the
it um so with that um I will take
questions if there are any but most
likely uh if it's of a technical nature
either Mr Tracy or hopefully Marty
Carlin can answer um specific questions
about what this would do for the
individual and for the retirement system
okay are there any questions for
representative
sh yeses pearon you chair thank you
representative shu is is the concern
from this individual
the due to a little bit of a complexity
to to meld group one time and group two
time together or is this really someone
who wants to collect their pension while
they're drawing a salary in another
position no I don't believe that's
what's being contemplated uh I think it
is is the concern about having 30 years
plus in group two and then uh this
individual likely due to his age uh
stands to reason he would be working
another five possibly 10 years and those
last five to 10 years would be group
one um I think Mr Tracy can tell you
more
detail um as the Commissioners
considered this obviously since it was a
Personnel M they went into executive
session so I'm sure he can impart um as
as is able to be made public uh about
their
considerations thank you other questions
for representative
Shu representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair um is it
not the case representative Shu that the
commissioners as the administrators of
the county have the County's best
interests uh in at heart and uh and and
and have endorsed this uh this proposal
uh for us to
consider um I would assume that to be
the case but since commissioner Tracy is
here I would let him Express
that yes okay I will I will address that
question to him when it's his time thank
you commissioner r has called in to
express her support she can't make the
meeting um I do have a question
representative Shu I don't if you know
the answer if this person is Exempted
from participating in the retirement
system will the county be paying the
approved
liability on on his
salary um again I would refer that to uh
commissioner Tracy I would think that
the uh Commissioners looked at
that thank you thank
you anyone
else um representative sh is there a
particular reason why this this is not
just for counties this is for
municipalities as well why were
municipalities included in this if this
is really
start that that is the current law
municipalities have this ability all
that this bill does is add the words and
counties and Board of Commissioners as
the approving Authority my
apologies that's one of the reasons that
um I don't see it as a large Wrinkle in
the plan um all that this would do is
add Poss possibly and not everyone would
take advantage of it the administrative
officers for counties and as you know we
have 10 counties in New Hampshire so at
the most this would only involve 10
individuals thank you representative
fellows thank you madam chair um
representative Shu do you know if this
provision that exists now for the
municipalities if that was part of the
original legislation when they set up
the retirement system or if it came
about sometime since
then um I'm sorry representative fellas
I did not check the statute to see the
adoptive dates um I don't know if um
Miss smling has the ability to check
that at the moment perhaps she could
tell us I'm I'm sure the section has
been amended many times times it and we
it would take a bit of research to
determine which of the changes included
that most of 100a has been amended
multiple times
true it likely uh would date back I
believe there was a major overhaul at
one time and that's
probably what you would find as
recent represent sitech this may be for
Mr trachy uh but I'll ask the question I
know of one municipality that
hired someone who had uh group one this
is all group one uh the person
established that they had in
mind an
LLC he was the sole employee of the
LLC and the town hired the LLC to do the
be the town
manager and uh got got away got around
it in that way uh is are you aware of
that situation uh is that just uh a
thought um no I'm not actually aware of
that I suspect that may have been the
town of Salem might have been might have
been thank
you and speak for sale baile you have a
question thank you madam
chairman just for somebody knew what's
group one and group
two um probably Marty Carlin would be
the best person to describe that um I
can tell you uh briefly representative
that group two tends to be First
Responders firefighters police
officers uh who have different um
contribution rates and return rates and
regulations involving their part of the
uh retirement system group one tends to
be teachers and regular state employees
and Municipal Employees but I think if
you want more details than that uh Mr
Carlin is probably the best person to
answer thank you yes the the useful
distinction is group two is specifically
defined so that it policemen fire
Corrections Officers and that's about it
everyone else is group one and group two
pays more but they are not subject to
Social
Security all right commissioner
try thank you madam chair and and
members of the committee my name is
Stuart Tracy and I'm a marac County
Commissioner and I want to thank
representative Shu for bringing this um
this amendment forward as she stated
this is a a piece of legislation that
was considered in 2020 and U passed by
the house on the consent calendar but uh
got bogged down and tabled in the Senate
because of uh covid and it it had the
same fate as U many many other bills
and I don't think the Senate's action
was any prejudice against the bill it
was just that it it wasn't going to
reach the uh the floor of the Senate uh
for 2020
consideration um in marac County and in
obviously this will apply to every
County but what we were looking for in
this legislation is the ability to have
a county executive have the same rights
and and uh
opportunities as administrators of
municipalities that currently have the
option to opt out of the retirement
system and that's what we're uh hoping
we can do in Mart County we have an
opportunity to keep um a very good
employee who's currently U the
correction
superintendent um and we are considering
and would like to have him become the
County Administrator but
this um issue of the retirement the
group two Etc is is an issue with him
and we would certainly like to
accommodate him um and others obviously
this would apply to to all the counties
and their County Executives but um so
that's the story behind it um I did uh
have communications with commissioner
Reen and as I understand she has
registered her support commissioner
Spalding up contacted him he's away but
Peter Spalding is the third commissioner
and uh we've had conversations about uh
various ways of trying to to address
this situation and I would feel with
most confidence that um he would also be
supportive but I I didn't make the
connection this morning but um so
obviously the the board is very
sympathetic to being able to keep um the
employee of our current um correction
superintendent who we hope will become
the uh the County Administrator and I'd
be glad to answer any
questions representative Schmidt has a
question thank you madam chair uh Mr
Tracy uh it's good to see you again
you're looking pretty commission Arial I
have to say uh uh from the old days when
uh when you used to be a member of the
Edna committee um but is is it not the
case that
this gentleman whom I don't know uh is a
valued employee of the uh of of mar
County that you wish to re retain in
your service that's correct yes yeah and
uh followup Madam chair follow up and
and and in order to enable him to uh to
continue to work on the County's behalf
uh that the Commissioners have uh
entertained this this concept and
and you're there to endorse it on their
behalf on behalf of the commission
that's correct yes okay well and and uh
thank you very much that that confirms
my
suspicions thank you and it's good to
see you representative stage nice to see
you too
Stuart so commissioner I had a question
this bill doesn't seem to specify it
exactly but would the County be willing
or I would expect the county to continue
to pay the approved
liability portion of the contribution
for any employee that was Exempted is
that your understanding as
well um when you brought that up Madam
chair it's the first time I heard that
issue raised and and so I'm not quite
sure how to address that and and um I'd
have to do a little bit more research
about that but um I would assume that
folks who are Exempted from the
retirement system I'm not sure what the
approved liability would be and how that
would be calculated um but that's
something we would definitely look into
but as I said this is the first I've
heard of that Madam
chair okay representative fellows thank
you madam chair um commissioner tury so
when I look at the statute one of the
things I see is that the exemption
applies to a person at initial um hiring
or appointment but we're talking about a
position here that's you are currently
employing so how do you think
this change to statute
will um help the situation that you're
dealing with um the the person in Mart
County that's under consideration is
currently the correction superintendent
so he would then be taking a new
position with the county as the County
Administrator
so yes to follow up if that's the
uh um a different position and and it
would have to be before he he accepted
the position which is why he's been uh
in the
acting
administrator for a while
now so my followup question is it well
the follow-up has to do with the fact
that it says initial hire and this
person was hired a long time ago um he's
just moving to a different position
which frequently happens and the
retirement system has an option for how
you uh calculate the retirement for a
person who's been in group two and group
one it's kind of like an average of the
benefits you know between the two
although I don't know the specific
details of that so why isn't that a
solution that would work but I I don't
see initial
hiring how you get past that part of it
so if you could just address those two
issues well um he's um been employed by
um the state of New Hampshire as I
understand it and the Department of
Corrections he's also been employed by
Sullivan County at one point and marac I
believe he's been at marac County for
about six years but um he's been in the
position of Correction
superintendent so this is now a
consideration for his employment as
County Administrator so that that would
be where it would come under the new
hire
category that that would be my
interpretation on
it so so just to follow up the second
half of the question had to do with
there's a mechanism in place for how you
can kind of like average somebody who's
been in group two and group one did you
look at that option that's not
satisfactory uh that's not something
that's satisfactory to as I understand
and I don't want to speak for the
employee or get into specifics about
that but um generally speaking what
we're asking for is the same allowance
that's given to city and Town
administrators so uh we think that it's
um a very legitimate request on behalf
of the counties and that those uh
positions and there's only 10 in the
state that would qualify potentially
qualify for um this provision um in in
terms of the melding of the group one
and two I I I don't know how that would
play out with this specific person I
don't know the details of that
thank
you thank you madam chair and thank you
store for coming and testifying I just
want to get clarification because I've
heard it explain two different ways um
is this
individual with the corrections or is he
I've also heard the statement that he is
also the acting Chief
administrator he's currently the
correction super superintendent and he's
the acting County Administrator so he is
you know still in the acting
capacity so and I just want to follow
back then to representative fellow's
question as to how you get around that
if he's acting and this is supposed to
go into the effect at the time of
initial hiring or appointment if he's
appointed as acting he's already in the
position so how does this get around
that well it it would certainly apply if
and when he becomes the actual uh County
Administrator so that would be the
actual date of hiring so it would be
specific to a date upon which he assumes
the title of County
Administrator thank you thank
you yes thank you um I think uh in
response to that thinking about it and
as chair of the Marram County delegation
I will say that this individual was
hired as um the corrections
superintendent by the county and has
only been act as administrator in the
absence of the former
administrator uh to my mind and I think
what um commissioner Tracy is saying is
they have not officially appointed him
as the
administrator so the statute says upon
hiring or appointment so at the date
that he is officially appointed the
administrator to my mind that's what
meets the uh demands of the statute
thank
you very much represent black
us all right
PE mam chair the this position within
the county historically has been a group
one position is that
correct that's as far as yes that's
correct so then this this
position has
responsibility um to the unfunded
liability there's historical
responsibility to to that debt so I have
serious concerns about the county making
this position exempt without
reassurances and safeguards that this
that the debt that needs to be paid for
this position will actually
occur
so representative to address that again
um as I mentioned to the chair um the
unfunded liability aspect of this um
question is one that we had not heard
before
uh we have um you know sought legal
counsel relative to how to address that
um but that has not been an issue that
has been presented to us and if it is an
issue then and it's something that we're
liable for the county would certainly um
step up to that
but I have not um heard of it being an
issue and we would assume the liability
if it is
necessary thank
you
uh represent citech uh thanks Mr Tracy
how is he uh holding two full-time jobs
how is he perform two full-time jobs I
guess well he he's um very well skilled
as you can imagine if we're considering
him for County Administrator um he does
have um tremendous support at the
corrections level and um in the
Commissioner's Office uh on the finance
side and the administration ative side
of both um operations so um it has been
difficult at times but um he's a very
skilled gentleman and he's been able to
uh stand up to it thank
you
uh I was wondering if the position of
County Administrator is an appointed
position or you go op do a
uh job search or whatever how does it
how is it normally
filled well um that's that's a good
question representative um it's it's
appointed and it's it's a position that
serves um it's appointed by the County
Commissioners and um I'm not sure how
they have done searches in the past but
I do remember way back during my tenure
um I was a county commissioner from 1988
to 2000 and we were able to
um fill a position of County
Administrator back then with uh you know
the Commissioners uh doing you know I
wouldn't say a broad search or or
whatever but I think it's up to the
discretion of the Board of Commissioners
in each County as to how they handle the
requirements for posting it and
advertising
Etc thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair uh a
question has just Arisen that that I'd
like to speak to um because I think it's
it it's important for the midi to hear
uh the that it's not unheard of uh for
uh uh counties uh in the case of a truly
skilled uh uh and extraordinary
individual uh to have somebody serving
in multiple roles uh as the delegation
chair in Strafford County uh I I'm aware
of the fact that straford County employs
a single individual who is the County
Administrator and also the nursing home
administrator uh a role of uh quite
higher level in terms of numbers of
people um and also complexity of U of um
individual responsibility with frail
individuals atend at the end of their
life um and Stafford County has had one
person do this job for the 20 years that
I've been in the uh in in stford County
politics um so there's nothing
extraordinary about this when you have
the right kind of person and when you
have the right kind of person you need
to keep that person so I think that's
important for the committee to be aware
of thank
youor sh you have another
question uh just to comment madams if
there's no one else uh wai in to speak
um again as chair of the delegation and
um our honorable chair is the former
chair of the delegation for Mar County
also uh I we are in a strange position
we had uh as representative Schmidt said
our former
administrator uh was a long-term very
trusted employee uh who knew every
aspect of the budget for 25 I believe
years
who then retired and the Commissioners
went out of the county and uh hired an
individual who
just I don't want to cast dispersions
but was um not adequate to the job I'll
just put it that way and when that
individual left um somewhat abruptly um
this individual stepped up and and just
started doing what needed to be done and
um as commissioner Tracy says he's an
extraordinary individual to be able to
Jud uh position uh along with
specifically being the superintendent of
the House of
Corrections thank
you Mr Carlin from the retirement system
is here and several of us have questions
for him so I'd like to recognize
Marty Carlin uh thank you madam chair
again for the record my name is Marty
Carlin representing the New Hampshire
retirement system uh nhrs uh did not
have a position last year on House Bill
1561 which is the same language as the
amendment proposed uh this year for
House Bill 141 um this would at Max uh
impact 10 potential positions that are
membership um required in the retirement
system that would become membership
optional um the uh Municipal exemption
for chief administrative officer Town
manager Etc has been in uh 100a since
1973 um you know and there are
communities that do uh exercise that
option uh not I don't I don't have a
count on how many do um but basically
it's something that the governing body
at the time of initial hire for that
position um you know can make that
election to the retirement system for
the person not to be enrolled um so it's
it's the statute a22 is hired for the
specific position so in the case of an
incumbent uh you know with that employer
who's in a in a different position where
membership is required it wouldn't be an
issue it's Point initial hiring or
appointment for the chief administrator
uh position is is when that option would
take take effect um we we read the
statute um initial to be so when
somebody is hired for that specific
position um and the only other thing I
would mention because it it came up is
there there are there is something
called split benefits where someone with
service in group one and group two uh
would get a a benefit um you know based
on their service in each in each group
uh however um and I don't know if this
is the case uh in the county issue but
in general terms if someone moves from a
group two police and fire position into
a group one uh employer and teacher
position there's a couple of uh benefits
associated with group two that don't
transfer over into group one um they
would they would lose eligibility for
that those are there's a um a 50% uh
benefit uh paid to a surviving spouse if
the the retiree passes away and there's
no actual reduction on that 50% and and
also for a group two members who are in
service on uh June 30th of 2020 uh I'm
sorry June 30th of 2000 uh when they
retire they would be eligible for the
medical subsidy which is an insurance
premium offset if you're getting your
insurance through your former employer
um so that that that can be a fairly um
significant loss there so I'm not sure
if that applies in this case but um
group two members uh do have those two
benefits that they would lose switching
into group
one thank you Mr Carlin do the
municipalities that exempt their Chief
administrator from the membership of the
retirement system pay the UA
contribution on those salaries they do
not the the the Lo the Lost salary if
you will or the Lost contributions on
that position um you know are just sort
of spread out among the other you know
14,000 or so employees in group one um
you know and and um you know it it's
quite quite a number of decimals out on
the employer rate when you when you
round out you know the contributions
lost for uh you know a single exempt
position thank you representative
Pearson thank you madam chair hello
Marty
hello can the nire retirement system
calculate what the UA is
for this
position as of right now uh we don't
have a handy way um to do that like you
know we haven't done that in the past
even you know for individuals because
it's you know it is a you know it's it's
a multi-employer plan and it's it's sort
of an aggregate calculation I mean that
I can't say it's not impossible but it's
something we would probably have to go
to our actuary for um you know and get
um you know you know pay some money to
get a calculation I'm not sure what they
what they would certify how how valid
that number is um because it's it's
you're really when you're looking at one
individual you're looking at who did
they work for in 2001 and what was the
liability that year were they in group
one or in group two so so that there's
you know it's a lot of equs mar not not
for the the person we're speaking of
we're talking about the position the
county that positions UAA not not an
individual car the annual reports that
the retirement system puts out and that
I I treasure have a statement that
there's so much for the normal
contribution and so much for the UA and
wouldn't that number for group one be a
very close
approximation yeah you I I see what
where you're going representative yeah
there is you know the total amount um
you know for group one uh member
employee contributions beginning in July
is it's 14 point something perc and
about 72 to 75% is attributable to the
unfunded liability so so we do have a
breakdown of the rate how much is the
normal cost how much is unfunded and how
much is the medical subsidy so you know
to get a backof the envelope um you know
calculation you would look at the salary
you know for the position being Exempted
and then what what is the UA rate for
that year and that that you'd get a
number that way it wouldn't it wouldn't
be
attributable to the history of that
position but as a snapshot at time it
would show what the percentage that
everybody's paying for the UN unfunded
for all their positions thank
you represent
Shu thank you madam chair I would just
um quote from the fiscal note that
originally came on House Bill
1561 the the actuary for the retirement
system stated the estimated impact is
assumed to be less than
[Music]
0.01% of the entire payroll for New
Hampshire retirement system
contributions that was as of last year
obviously thank you other other
questions there's couple of there
representative
Schulz thank you madam chair I just
wanted to make sure I understand this
correctly so this is already available
to uh cities and towns correct correct
correct okay just making sure thank
you representative uh
fellows thank you madam chair I just um
Wanted clarification about Mr Carlin
mentioned the medical subsidy so I
understand the unfunded
liability is is there something
comparable like if we're if we're
potentially going to consider asking the
um the the municipalities and and
counties to cover the unfunded liability
is there also some kind of percentage
for the medical in group two uh yes yes
there is a uh oh in yeah group two it's
it's a 3.21% of pay and actually while
um while we were asking the question I
did look up the unfunded for a group one
uh position for political subdivision is
11.77% of pay effective July 1 of this
year thank you thank you repr L thank
you madam chair and um I suppose my
question is best
um um because you and your colleagues
have I'm sure deliberated on this more
than anybody see the advantages for the
county but in your discussions um have
there been any uh disadvantages to the
county what's the downside for the
county in
this uh I'm not sure I understand the
question but you mean if the legislation
doesn't pass or does I could rephrase
that make could simpler
um every
time this is a concession of sorts and
so there's got to be an upside those are
clear to me the upsides what's the
downside for the county uh in this
[Music]
proposition uh I I
guess there it's a win-win as far as I'm
concerned but I guess maybe uh losing
our current uh correction superintendent
as correction superintendent and moving
to uh a new position I mean he he's a a
well-respected correction superintendent
and he's done a great job at our
department of corrections so perhaps
that's the downside but I think the
biggest downside in the whole picture is
um the possibility of losing someone of
his caliber and and it's not just a Mart
County issue I think it's an issue in
the public sector across the board where
if you have good people you want to find
a way to keep them and um if they're
doing a good job um do what you can to
to keep them employed and and um
promoting from within is something that
we've always um promoted as a board and
and we like to look at the talent we
have and so that's the biggest upside is
uh being able to retain the talent that
we
have other there other
questions yeah represent thank you thank
you Mr kin Ju Just just so we can put it
in plain English and and and the rest of
us can fully understand this if if this
position now becomes removed from group
one
and there is
no
statutorily driven requirement to pay
back any calculated unfunded liability
will this
this debt that the county specifically
incurred would that now be basically
placed on the shoulders of all other
contributors within the retirement
system I.E other other
municipalities yes to to the extent if
if the unfunded percentage is I'm going
to say 11% for round numbers and the
County administrator again for round
number purposes salary is $100,000 there
$111,000
that all of the all of the employers
collectively would have to contribute to
make up for the loss of that position
you know including some some proportion
coming from the county itself but uh you
know it's it's an aggregate thing so so
it would be shared by all the
employers thank you our representative
sitech yeah I'm not sure for whom this
question is maybe representative should
uh this is uh this legislation may seem
quite reasonable and consistent with the
municipalities sauce for the goose and
sauce for the gander
but uh suppose this person comes from
Iowa and is 40 years old and expecting
to work 25 years perhaps uh why should
that person be Exempted even though this
it seems like this bill is crafted
tailored for one per for a particular
situ situation that that's unusual that
perhaps unusual that somebody coming
from out of the blue why should that
person be
Exempted uh that's a question at large
it's sore of my mind that I think that
was addressed to me um I will just I'm
not sure I will just say that um this is
only going to apply to this one
individual if if the county wants to try
and exempt a future um individual that
would be a question for the uh
Commissioners to take up at that
time thanks
representative thank you madam chair
this is a question from Mr
Carlin so I I know that when a group two
person retires
there can be an issue about um overtime
pay being used as a portion of their
what do you call it average I don't know
whatever that average salary is that you
can compute with the highest years
compensation there's a special
Provisions for that this this position
that we're specific situation we're
talking about here has something that's
seems
um somewhat related to that situation
because we're not talking about a new
hire coming from totally from the
outside um and how that would impact the
system but this particular person has
accumulated something that's like that
special
overtime pay special duty pay and has a
higher salary right now because of that
is is will that extra exra money above
what was his normal salary as just the
um superintendent of Corrections going
to be treated differently than his
normal salary um it it it it would
depend on whether or not he was vested
before January 1st of 2012 which is um
you know the effective day to some of
the uh major changes to the pension plan
uh enacted back in 2011 if if someone
who is vested uh prior to that date uh
any any compensation paid uh during
their um you know their working life
overtime uh things like that plus any
acrs of you know on you sick vacation
time all count in that average final
compensation calculation for people
hired after um July 1 of 2011 overtime
still counts for them as well um you
know but those end of career payouts for
time approvals don't count anymore and
for for the the folks sort of in that in
that middle tier um you know there's
there's some limitations on how much is
counted um you know but in terms of
specifically overtime any overtime he
worked in his career would fall be if it
fell within his high three or high five
years of AFC you know we would still
calculate it um anything if if the if
this person is working in an exempt
position for the county none of that
salary is going to count toward the
pension going forward it would just be
the past
service yeah just follow up follow up
yeah just it are there any current
situations or has this ever come up
before with a person getting about a
person being doing a job that's like
half group two and partly group you know
partly group a position that's group one
and group two at the same time NOP you
can you can only be one or the the other
so you know you know the the you know
the person can switch positions into you
know a statutorily defined group two
position or group one position you know
or if they're working in a position
that's reclassified by the legislature
they would switch but you know their
service in the group they were in you
know is is distinct you know from you
know the group one time and and um you
know is is distinct from the group two
time but there's no positions that that
are
both okay thank you
other other
questions representative
goie thank you madam chair and this
question I guess go to Mar Marty
um in listening to this whole
conversation if this
individual is hired and
working
as a group two individual but also
is in an acting position in a group one
scenario as
well um how do those benefits get
divided or split or are we
now paying some of the salary that he's
acting in as a group one position going
towards his group two
benefits um I I think it it I can't
speak to this specific case because I
don't have the you know the the County's
agreement with this individual I I
haven't seen it or had a chance to
review it t typically in general terms
um you know if it's somebody who has a
group two position um with some respons
if there's a separate agreement over and
above you know the superintendent's
position to do some extra County we may
count
that well actually no let me take that
back I think generally speaking if if
the majority of the work an individual
is doing is in is in group group one or
group two we're going to count the
salary in that group with with that's
their primary
occupation uh but again I don't for this
specific case I I don't I don't know how
we're uh treating that I would I didn't
you know know about the case until the
hearing today um in any
detail okay I just I'm just trying to
figure out how he can be acting in one
position as group one and also in group
two and combining those two if it's
going towards group two benefits then
it's there's a big difference I I I I
think we we we look at which which POS
which position is the person spend is
their primary occupation I think there
were cases where you know in some of the
smaller towns there was a you know fire
chief building inspector you know and
and the building inspector was 10 hours
a week and you know the chief was a
full-time job and you know I believe in
those sort of historical situations you
know counted the salary towards the
group two
okay and and
they um comment there that at the time
of initial hiring or appointment to be
able to opt out that wouldn't affect us
even though he's act hired as a group
two but is acting that position that
wouldn't exempt him I think you know
there's a there's a difference between
somebody serving in an acting capacity
and somebody being hired for the
specific position that that that's how
we would look at it you know from a
legal perspective and that that is an
optional exemption so if the
the um somebody had a question for
representative shuart about somebody
who's you know 40 years old and comes to
New Hampshire you know they they
probably part of their negotiations with
the employer with the county they want
to say hey I want to be in nhrs it's not
like all of the positions are exempt
going forward it's you know and if this
individual were to leave in the county
the next County Administrator you know
wanted to be in group one or was was
coming from you know somewhere else you
know that the whole the whole um
scenario could play out again
differently the next time around thank
you other
questions represent
fellows did you did you call on me you
had your hand up oh I the the sound
quality isn't always that good thank you
madam chair um I just want to ask Mr
Carlin if
if he it sounds like what I'm hearing is
that somebody could be in group group
two for 30 let's say 25 years and
they've been their uh grandfathers so
you know beyond farther back than on
2012 and they've earned that the medical
subsidy and the um the
50% for the spouse that if they move to
group one for just one year then they
lose those benefits and that doesn't
that doesn't seem
fair the way the statute is constructed
it's like it it applies to the those
benef if if you you have to retire from
that group uh to qualify for the
benefits if you if you re retire from
group two um if you try retire from
group one uh you would lose them I mean
because because they're not group one
benefits so it so it you know in terms
of the eligibility for those it's it's
the group you retire from
yes representative laus related to that
question so in this case if this
person's been in group two long enough
that they've uh you know they're
eligible for those benefits in
particular the retirement medical uh I
guess it's a subsidy if they move to a
group one
position then they'll lose it when they
do retire assuming you know they're in
group one when they retire however is it
the case that if they uh if this bill
passes and they opt out of the
retirement
system when they retire they would uh in
effect be retiring from group two and
they would be eligible for that benefit
is that correct
yes thank
you there's also of course the uh
earlier retirement date on two I would
presume that after 31 years this person
eligible to retire from group two but
probably not for group one is that
likely to be the
case I can't say what this individual
will do um you know if if if the law
passes and he takes the new position but
if he was eligible to retire in group
two you know you know has the age and
the the requisite service they they
could retire
um doesn't happen that often I mean
there are a number of
there's more exempt positions with the
state and certain agencies where you
know we see that more somebody retires
in group two and moves into a a
membership optional position such as a
commissioner or Deputy Commissioner
things like
that thank you are there any other
questions Mr
trainy uh Madam chair I just wanted to
thank you and the committee for the
opportunity to address and your for your
consideration of it and wanted to note
that it's always special to come before
the house Edna committee because uh 44
years ago I was a freshman on house Edna
and I served six wonderful years and
enjoyed every minute of it and I
certainly have an appreciation for the
work you people do in that committee so
thank you very much and I'm sure the uh
question of the retirement system has
not changed in those years we heard we
heard lots of uh bills regarding the
retirement system and I would have
thought by 44 years that uh everything
would have been straightened out but it
there's always different nuances as uh
is demonstrated by this bill today but
thank
you other
questions okay is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on this amendment to
House Bill
okay seeing none I will close the public
hearing all
right for motion ready for motion yes to
move to pass for House Bill
575 is there a
second second by
Schmidt Madam chair can I just ask that
the people that are in the big room
there if they try to speak right into
their microphones because it's loud but
it's not very clear I will say uh Sally
sorry representative fellows this is uh
representative Schultz I think it's
actually that the sound volume to us
from the room is too
loud my understanding of um AV issues is
it's it's it's distorted because how
it's coming across to those of us on
Zoom is it's coming across too loudly
and therefore somewhat
distorted all right thank you there is
some Distortion we all have to speak
more slowly and clearly than is often
our case so
um who was the
second it was Madam chair Peter Schmidt
you representative leus do you wish to
speak to your motion I do thank you uh
Madam chair the uh basically what this
does is uh for
uh for the licenses that are fected so
cosmetologists manicurists and
aestheticians it
allows and currently they can uh do an
apprenticeship um for their the
education
required um this would value the
apprenticeship at the same level as um
you know going to a school it sets the
hours the
same and uh also
so at the end of the bill it currently
they can get an apprenticeship license
um if they're going to a school or if
they're in an apprenticeship
program um the minor change would allow
them to get it you know even if they're
it's Andor so they could do part of
their training I suppose in a school and
part in apprenticeship and
U and the other thing to realize is that
an existing la and what would continue
is it has to be an apprenticeship
program that's approved by the
board um or certain other bodies and
they still have to to pass the exam
so you know a good apprenticeship
program you know could be as good or in
some ways better than uh than going to a
school and uh you know we should leave
the option of doing either one of them
and uh you know I don't think it's
reason to be requiring twice as many
hours in some cases for the
apprenticeship in a school thank you
repres uh actually Madame chair um I
misheard the bill number when
representative leus made his motion i i
i misheard it and thought we were I was
seconding the motion uh on the bill we
just the amendment we were just talking
about so I have no
comment actually I was I think I should
withdraw my motion if that's permissible
because
um it was a result of the Mish
hearing all right is there another
second then representative Bailey
seconds do you wish to speak to your
second
no so Madam chair are are we dealing
with an amendment to this to
575 no not that I know oh just the bill
okay well
not hearing everything correctly okay
because I didn't have an amendment so
that's fine the reason one everything's
fine representative faran you wish to
speak um yes I guess this is a question
for somebody on the committee who supp
the bill I was not at this hearing I'm
just substituting for the day but I know
from past experience that the
cosmetologists are they're very very
strong advocates for their own cause and
also licensing is something that we're
often uh
we're often attacking because it seems
like at least to some members of
legislature I'm not ping anyone's
motives but it's commonly viewed by
non-c cosmetologists as a profession
that's not really a profession whereas a
cosmetologist feel the opposite so my
question is um did the cosmetologists
come out for the uh hearing like they
often do and also like who who at like
no theologist did not come out in in uh
force on this issue the only person who
testified against it was the owner of a
beauty
school okay
so okay great thanks so and what did the
owner the beauty school say about it or
they said that an hour of apprenticeship
is not is only worth half as much as an
hour in the
school okay
thanks which I'm not surprised
is there anyone else who wishes to
speak hey in that case the motion is
ought to pass by representative leus and
the clerk can call the
RO representative Bry
yes representative pearon yes represent
representative Le yes representative
algro yes representative Bailey yes
representative
lanara yes representative
saso yes representative goalie
no Representative
shill
no representative Judy no representative
Schmid no reprentative
Schultz no representative
fellow no
representative
Horgan no representative Roda no
O'Brien no the chair yes 10 to nine to
recommend all right that will go on the
regular calendar is there
someone to write a Minority
Report all right hearing none no no
minor Madam chair yes yes I I apologize
for confusing Everyone by not making a
motion on the previous uh hearing I had
to go to the ladies room um I at this
point if it's permissible I will move um
the amendment
0594 to House Bill
141 you're moving on to pass and the
amendment I second that as I intend to
do the first
time all right that is amendment
you wish to speak to your your motion
representative sh well I think we've
probably said most everything that
needed to be said U I will just
reiterate that uh this committee passed
this exact language uh last year by a
vote of
16-2 uh the House of Representatives
felt it was um proper to pass it on the
consent calendar uh and
unfortunately the Senate did not uh was
not able to take it up properly um I
will also point out that um we heard
that
the um bill would only involve at the
most 10
individuals and it would be on an
individual basis this would not go
forward for the position it would be
taken up each time an individual in this
position is
considered um and um there's one other
thing I was gonna
say oh that that the um statute already
provides this uh same opportunity for
municipalities and Mr Carlin did note
that there aren't very many
municipalities even that take it out so
I doubt that it would uh actually affect
very many
individuals and I would appeal to the
members of the committee to please
consider maram County's position thatth
this is a very good employee and if
we're not able to accommodate him we may
actually lose his
Services thank you Schmid do you wish to
speak to your second
I do Madam chair thank you very much so
I I think it's important for the
committee to know uh what people
with considerable experience uh in
County government uh have learned uh as
a result of that experience and I have
served uh in straford County uh as the
chair for multiple terms uh and I know
what a key employee the County
Administrator is is um we happen to be
blessed in stford County with someone
who has served for um well my 20 years
in uh in County government and in Dover
City Council government uh and um when
you have a a key employee and the County
Administrator is the key employee uh in
the county uh who is an excellent
individual uh that you have the
experience of uh you see that he or she
is uh compatible uh with the needs of
the county the needs of the office uh
and also uh the personalities of the
commission that he or she serves um then
maintaining uh that relationship with
that employee is in the best interest of
the county its citizens its taxpayers uh
and also all of its
employees uh so to the degree that may
county has such an individual um that
they've already had doing uh apparently
multiple positions joint positions uh
for five or six years uh and someone who
had prior experience of the um the
county the corrections position as well
this this means this person is
extraordinarily uh knowledgeable about
two of the the key ke positions in the
County government uh I can't emphasize
too strongly how important it is to
maintain such a person and and and that
person's reliability so I strongly urge
my colleagues uh to vote Yes on this
motion just one quick correction if I
may Madam chair this this individual in
marac county has only been doing this
job for u a bit over a year thank
you pearon thanks
corre I do um I I think that this this I
know this is a complicated matter in the
sense that it's a it's a rewrite
Amendment um but this this is
a this is an Avenue for a for a county
to basically erase its debt to the
pension system and I don't like that at
all I think that there needs to be an
amendment to this I mean I'm not
necessarily opposed to the the idea of
the 10 County U Chief
Executives having the ability
to but concern is the debt the debt the
prior debt that comes with that and I
this this really should be addressed
here this is you know the the idea of
repaying the unfunded liability is just
that repaying
and I think there needs to be some
language added into this to ensure that
that debt be taken care of in over a
period of time not not all at once that
could without having numbers in front of
me I can I can see how that might be POS
you know
problematic but this is something that
is that is a substantial issue within
the pension system and the legislature
having having substantial pension
liability and and I just I can't stomach
voting for something that allows a
county to just erase its the debt that
it's incurred over this so without
without an amendment to this to include
the a way to deal with that I I can't I
can't go along with
this represent
fellows uh thank you madam chair just to
let you know my internet is a little
unstable here so I
have my picture off um after list
listening to all a testimony for this I
I don't support this amendment what I
would like to work on or see if we can
do I with this bill or maybe it will
have to wait a while is to address the
situation that somebody could be um a
long-term employee in group two and
would lose those two key benefits the um
medical subsidy and the in the
50%
um retirement payment to the spouse
just because they move into group one so
I mean I would you know I would like to
somehow um address excuse me address
that for the people who who are hired
prior to um 2012 in group two but not
make um this exception for the county
administrators I was one of the people
who voted against this two years ago
because I just think it's a slippery
slope I think everybody ought to be in
the um retirement system with the
exception of people who are appointed
for a specific term like like the
Commissioners the state state
Commissioners those those sorts of
people thank you
so representative
scitech
uh there's there's no good vote for me
in this thing um
the things that I don't like
hearing are that he's been doing this
for a year there's nobody that good and
representative Schmid has made a case
that the man's Irreplaceable and the
more that's the lady do protest too much
there's nobody that
good on the other
hand this when the municipalities were
Exempted we did not think about the
UA and it just seems
wrong to be inconsistent with a job
that's basically the
same that would I I representative
fellows has on to something I am not
prepared to do the work to bring an
amendment such that both the
municipalities and this person as
representative Pearson says it's okay
that we exempt him but not from the Deb
because the UN the debt that he would be
paying or that the county would be
paying is now a
ghost and uh Marty Carlin pointed out
it's
0.00001 that's like saying a little
adultery is okay but not too much
adultery it's just
wrong so look I I'm I'm gonna vote for
the darn thing I don't I don't like it I
think that's the lesser of the evils and
there I am
representative
leus yeah I uh I'm twin as well I I
agree uh at least to some extent with uh
Representatives Pearson and scitech um
I've got a problem with avoiding the
debt I mean I would actually
support um either here on a separate
bill having municipalities so where they
have people move on or exempt um paying
that debt although maybe since that's
been permitted back to the 70s that
wouldn't make any sense I know um on
just the issue of whether this
person you know should be able to opt
out of the system I I don't have a
problem with that in and of itself and I
understand this situation you know why
he'd want to do it and and why U you
know the county would want to let him do
it I also agree with the representative
fellows that uh there does seem to be a
problem where if somebody's uh been
group two long enough to be eligible for
certain benefits uh having them go away
just because they move you know maybe at
the end of their career to group one for
a while it doesn't seem right
either
I'm not sure at this point uh I will
mention to representative leus that the
the loss of benefits when moving from
group two to group one at toward the end
of your career is a reason why we keep
getting requests by the prisons for
example to allow individuals who move up
into management to retain their group to
status it comes up every year but um
might there be another way to fix it
just to allow them if they've been in
group to long enough to keep certain
benefits but maybe not the early
retirement I just wrote something that
would do that all right representative
Schulz thank you madam chair um I came
in today thinking I was going to vote
against this amendment I mean that the
whole uh debate about group one and
changing anybody from group one to group
two it's a difficulty it's certainly a
political lift but what sells me on
voting for it now is how close it is for
counties to be uh in alignment with what
is already allowed to happen in
municipalities it just seems like an
issue of fairness you know as to the
issue the bigger issue like the
discussion around Corrections agents I I
think you know giving folks a chance to
continue in public service jobs where
they've had a lot of experience is a
good idea but that's a bigger discussion
uh for today so to include just these
positions for the county I think just
seems to bring it in alignment and I I
happen to also know uh the specific
person we're talking about with maram
County he actually is pretty phenomenal
he's gotten some national attention for
some programs that he started in uh Mart
County Corrections and he's actually
been a great administrator I wish I
didn't in a way because this shouldn't
be personal right it should be something
we do without prejudice but just the
notion that municipalities already allow
for this is um I think a good sign that
this is the right thing to do and to
encourage good managers in public
service to continue on by not messing up
the group two status just seems like the
fair thing to do at this point for
whatever it's
worth
BR thank you madam chair my concern is
the unfunded balance um it doesn't
matter how small it is if we just
continue to do this it's GNA continue to
be larger and larger unfunded balance I
would entertain a motion that would say
that if this was something that people
chose to do that the municipal I mean I
don't I didn't realize the
municipalities weren't also paying the
unfunded
bounds so um I would entertain an
amendment to this bill that would
specify
that and I'd like to close the loophole
on the municipality unfunded balance as
well representative laus I also was not
aware that the municipalities wer paying
u in that case um if uh somebody is uh
interested in doing an amendment to fix
up some of the concerns um I would vote
against this amendment and you know
likely
support uh you know support the idea of
letting this person opt out as long as
some of concerns or
trust represent peon are you I am more
than willing to I'm more than willing to
work with representative fellows to
address um both of
those concerns in in uh and an amendment
to this absolutely we could do that in
uh post hastely represent SC uh I'm
going to throw in the for representative
Schultz uh it can personal there are I'm
willing to concede that the person has
the qualifications and it's really a
bill of attainer it applies to him only
which is fine we we are here to make to
deliberate we're not a
machine but I don't I think this is a
bigger picture than a than a simple
Amendment simple then an amendment for
the how you calculate the year a based
made what
percentage and we got
to involve the municipalities it should
be a comparable position in state
government municipal government should
be treated the same and I don't believe
when the lights go out that anybody's
going to have the gumption to actually
come forward with legislation I don't
think an amendment will do it we all go
home and have dinner and forget about it
unfortunately that's what's that's the
political reality because there's no
crying need here this is a relatively
minor
issue representative
Bailey thank you madam
chair
I'm I've heard several times that this
is just affecting 10 people but not
that's not entirely accurate if
everybody else in this system has to
pick up the cost of the unfunded
liability it's actually affecting quite
a few people and not just 10 I'm I'm
kind of new in town so I'm kind of
horrified that you've allowed two cast
systems to to develop where it's
actually worth not having five to 10
years of a pension in order to remain in
the higher
cast I mean I I I'm dumbfounded by it um
I don't think creating an exception for
one person
or 10 people when it's actually
offloading the cost to many many more
people is a legitimate solution to this
I'd be opposing it thank
you
represo thank you madam chair I uh agree
with representative fellows and I
certainly sympathize with the
County's uh desire to gra a really
qualified person that kind of
flexibility uh for merit based hiring I
think is really important I'm just
concern that this smacks too much of
legislation for one person I would like
to see us and the fairness issue was a
real one I would like to see us consider
this more either with an amendment if
that's possible or uh for it to be
retained so we can discuss it and U you
know craft legislation that affects more
than just one or 10 people
directly uh thank thank you very much
Madam chair um I just wanted to comment
my understanding the history on group
one and group two is that group two is a
public service jobs that people retire
from early or like the firefighter
police officer because they're more
physically demanding and that actually
U and actually quite quite often they'll
enter quite often they're only halfway
really halfway through their career so
they'll be doing something of a less uh
randing nature such as actually many uh
so some I didn't ask I should have asked
when they had it but there it's a there
are a substantial number of people who
leave group two earlier in the career or
mid after the standard 10 to 20 years
and then go do other do other work
including sometimes group one work with
different agencies in the in state
government and also of course this is a
symptom of a much more Global problem
reti with our state retirement system is
that we've been steadily reducing the
number of younger people who are paying
into it by not uh by you know shrinking
the size of government which I mean
there's good reasons for that but that
does mean there Fe workers and also then
shift more work you know contractors and
the stuff so we do have a situation
where it's bu to something there s like
a pyramid here but we've been taking
we've been chipping away at the base of
the pyramid so it's a unfortunately it's
in danger of collapse but I do think
probably for this one case this is
passing this bill is not a it's not a
bad idea to deal with this one case
where one
individual uh appears to be the choice
for a very important job and certainly
so that's what it that's what it takes
to solve this problem that's fine and
we'll be looking legislature will be
looking at this for many years to come
probably forever so
that's that's what I wanted to say in
favor of the amendment
thanks
thank you representative fellows um
thank you madam chair I I just wanted to
say I think I think we've got a couple
of things that we can work on and we can
come up with something but I'm not sure
if we can do it just with an amendment
that it might be better to retain it so
we can get retirement to give us some
financial information about making these
changes I have one comment I would like
to say that I'm glad that we're we've
got some
meaty a very meaty amendment to replace
a bill that we really don't want to pass
because it would need way too much work
to
fix that is the original House Bill 141
which
uh full of downshifting work to the m
municipalities see repres
goalie
thank you madam chair I just want to
briefly U make a comment that well we
talk about the unfunded aced liability
on these positions um and looking to
recoup it uh I think another question
that may be asked
is um currently municipalities are
allowed to do this that do
they pay for the unfunded acred
liability for that position if that
position was not in the system if that
individual prior was not in the
retirement system but now has opted to
take
benefits um I believe that they still
have to pay the unfunded acrude
liability for that rate um so we're
we're talking you could you can't have
it both ways where you accept it when a
new position comes in and you don't
accept it when they opt out um I I just
I'm not sure if uh you could you would
do that for the cities and towns
currently and if not um you know it's
part of the discussion to be
made thank you I believe
that you're you're absolutely right that
if we chose to amend this to require
municipalities as well as counties to
pay the UA there would be a a major
scream of outrage because they've been
doing it for 50 years Ling
UA U if if I may Madam chair yes sh yes
that's exactly the point that I was
going to make out um representative
Pearson is concerned about uh the
contributions to the U for 10 positions
but
currently um these exemptions exist for
all the municipalities in New Hampshire
which I believe right now number 240
some
odd and they
option uh so if if the concern is about
that and uh this committee wants to work
on an amendment to put that forward I
would ask to please do that as a
separate issue because I'm sure we're
going to hear major push back from the
municipalities and the municipal
Association against that idea because
that's going to be a major cost to them
um so please I would ask if you just
consider this particular bill which only
deals with the possibility of 10
positions right now we only had the one
individual that the bill was put forward
for from Sullivan County last year and
now Marram county found themselves in
the situ this year so uh I don't think
there are too many people that would
take advantage of it
but um I would just make the case that I
don't think this I doubt that if we
amended it to
accommodate those ideas that this would
pass at
all likely represent if I may follow up
on representative shu's thing uh I don't
know that this is a major expense it's
going to be a major insult we didn't
give them their 5% so we're going to
give going to stick them even more with
this uh proposed legislation I think
that just has to wait for another
environment not this one and uh
uh
anyway representative fellows um yes I
just wanted to say I haven't heard
anybody tell us exactly how many
Municipal
administrators are exempt because the
ones I've seen one my town they move
from one town to another and I I'm
guessing that they're that they're that
they didn't that they are in the
retirement system but I don't really
know how
many some a lot of some of the town the
real little towns they may have just a
part-time administrator so they wouldn't
be in it one way or the
other Mr Carlin do you have any
information on that since you're still
with us I don't think he
is I don't see his
name back
in I didn't him out if you want to back
[Music]
call we need a Bild to Pro to license
itinerant pedlers and town
managers well actually more importantly
for the little towns the Town
Administrator m not be a full-time
job right and in that case it wouldn't
be
eligible so is there any further
comments questions
discussion Madam chair I thank you well
my concern is at what point does this
end what's going to be the next
thing that people want to be Exempted
from from the retirement
system that's a very good question but I
will mention that we're currently seeing
a large wave of people that were hired
20 30 years ago coming into the age
where they're not interested in doing GR
group to work anymore and so we keep
seeing that the employers want to
promote them to management jobs and
they're reluctant because of the pension
issues I mean if you take a a group one
job when you when you've got 25 or 30
years into group two you're necessarily
delaying your retirement by probably 10
years
right something that can be addressed
because I think everybody in many people
feel that they their group two benefits
should not be compromised because they
have some group one service at the end
and when representative Gro when you and
representative fellows make the omnus
bill here I'll be happy to support that
considerations well you know we excuse
me um could we can't really talk about
are we yeah we could talk about this
because we're executing this right yes
this yeah so
so I just I just don't
uh I understand the issues but at the
same time when you take the job you take
the job and when you take the job take
if you want to switch jobs and you take
you take
the the packages that come with it I
just don't understand
how
um I just I I'm concerned about the
health of the retirement system and
maintaining it and I don't see how this
is helpful in that respect that's my
concern and if we need to look at the
whole thing as a I know this is this is
a hair ball
a hairball of a problem but if we look
at
it in that light then we may need
to look at it on a larger
scale sure nobody wants to hear on this
committee
but does anyone else have any uh
[Music]
remarks yes no be balls representative
fellows yes Madam chair can can you tell
me if he think it's feasible to address
the issue of um moving from group two
into group one and not losing the
benefits that you're be vested with Is
it feasible to try to just do this with
an amendment in the next week or two
week how however much time we've got the
short answer representative fellows is
no there's a lot involved and I'm
I'm not sure we could do a thorough job
and I'm fairly sure that a quick and
dirty job would be very
bad thank
you anyone else have a
comment the motion on the floor is to
adopt amendment 0594 to House Bill 141
which replaces the entire bill with the
no
Amendment all right no further
discussion we will call the
RO representative Roy no the clerk votes
representative Peterson me
representative did you vote Yes oh I
voted yes I'm sorry representative
Pearson no Representative yovich no
Representative leus no representative
Allegro no
representative Bailey no representative
Lara
yes representative Sant
naso
no representative
goes yes representative
sh yes representative Judy we
representative Schmidt yes
represent was that me I think uh yes
representative
fellows
no representative
huran uh on the amendment
yes uh representative
gr sadly
no representative
O'Brian yes the
chair
I'd have to say
no nine in
favor 10
opposed we're not hearing that can you
repeat the vote please representative
sitech there were nine Ys there were 10
Nays the motion does not succeed
[Music]
motion there are
other possible motions that we could
make at this point one would be to
retain the
bill and the other would be to uh
itl Madam chair I make a motion to
retain no second second all right um so
the motion is to retain by
representative brus seconded by
representative
Pearson any discussion
I'm sorry madam chair this is is this
the which
Bill House Bill
141 thank you
[Music]
141 if the bill is retained in this
current
form still be able to make a new
Amendment yes that's a very interesting
question can can you repeat the question
question was that if we retained the
bill would we also be retaining this
non- gerine
amendment so I would say open the
further
Amendment okay can I make a motion that
I see what we've got we sort have gotten
ourselves into a pickle here how about
if I make a motion that we reconsider
the vote that we just took on the
amendment
yes you may do so and then we we um
retain the bill so you're withdrawing
your moot your Mo motion to retain and
Recons and moving to reconsider the
motion of on the amendment correct I I
withdraw my motion to um
retain and I make a motion to reconsider
our vote on the amendment to house bill
Bill the nment house bill
575 M Madam chair I just point out that
you there is no motion for retain as
amended I mean the committee doesn't
actually adopt amendments we just
recommend that the house adopt
amendments so if that's the
goal interesting situation where we
don't want to pass the original Bill we
are we we kind of like the amendment but
we're we have many concerns that aren't
settled yet so we don't really want to
retain I don't believe we want to retain
House Bill
141 Mr
J I'm just I'm just here for the day so
but um I think the Full House the if we
we we could itl it and that would
prevent us from considering a bill next
year but that would only be a bill
establishing a p registry and in fact we
could okay even asked have our rules
suspended so we could have a past
registry so the Full House hasn't taken
any Vision one way or another on the
Amendments there's nothing prevent
someone from bringing in uh a similar
Bill even this year but certainly uh
next year to deal with the issue of a
county administrators who who are been
doing group two jobs so that that issue
um that issue anybody could introduce a
bill during the filing periods
regardless of the fact that this
amendment failed the committee that's op
that's the case then we itl the bill
here yeah to the floor with the intent
of killing him on the floor to when we
can handle that in committee but could
the subcommittee correct and bring a new
non
Amendment we can always bring in new
amendments that's normally subcommittees
do that so if we retain this bill
the subcommittee could make and fix a
new non amendment to it and bring it
back to us in
the could we just stop the executive
session and leave it open to further
Amendment uh yes we could representative
Le just a kind of a procedural question
I mean what would be the Practical
difference between retaining this bill
and planning on doing a new non- terine
Amendment and iing the bill and just
taking up a new bill next year
Madam chairman if I could interject just
to sort of piggyback on what
representative leus just said um there's
there's nothing that stops you from
establishing an ad hoc committee maybe
to work on the issue of you know
exempting ad chief administrative
officers in
counties um from retirement system and
that ad hoc committee could easily
develop a a new bill for the upcoming
session it might be a cleaner way of
posting in the calendar than continually
posting um House Bill 141 as it was
introduced Thank you
Pam that's exactly what I was going to
suggest that we we the committee can
take up any issue we want to uh and we
clearly have not resolved the issue with
regard to this Town Administrator County
Administrator whatever situ situation
and uh so we can cheerfully the itl the
uh the underlying bill which nobody
wants as far as I can tell and we can
deal with this issue uh separately and
uh on our own time in the
fall Madam chair if I may representative
sh yes I the one point I would say I
think the committee felt that some of
the issues in uh 141 did have Merit of
forming of the
registry um it was just some of the uh
stipulations that were put forward in
that bill that were objected to if we
itl it I have fear that that might
prevent that specific issue from coming
forward next year so I would say that we
do need to put either retain 141 or put
an amendment on it that um
releases that language so that it can be
brought forward next year thank you uh
representative Pearson has volunteered
to come up with a second
amendment a different non but related
nerine amendment
that that we could consider so I think
we will uh recess the executive session
until next
Monday we are meeting again anyway so
representative Gro has
uh I withdrawn my motion and representa
withdra okay so withdra we're we
have we have defeated the the amendment
on various issues but we we think it's
worthy of a little bit of work on the
part of one of our members so we're
going to sign him that
okay is this a ad hoc
subcommittee Excuse me yes s do we have
a motion did we do we have a motion to
reconsider on the floor at this
point that's the motion she withdrew I
believe yes that was the motion to
retain then she ation made a motion to
reconsider sub oh I okay I withdraw my
motion to reconsider thank you
represent excuse me yeah motion to adop
the amendment failed the all other
motions have been withdrawn so we will
recess this executive session in hopes
of getting
a different yes if it's a non gerain
Amendment we're going to need a hearing
are we not I think it should be close
enough to this one Miss Marling that's a
good
question I would have to defer to the
clerk on that one I don't want to uh get
out ahead of him well would you find out
for sure because we have a uh we have
noticed this main Amendment and we wish
to tweak it I think is the
way
I'll call and and um hopefully get a
hold of him right now thank you we'll
find out me while
we'll I don't
know I'm certainly willing to listen to
tweaking anything more than tweaking is
worries me and I think the
lousiest way the Le the least
way out I'll stick to my guns and P the
darn
thing that's
[Music]
that well with our feet both planted
firmly in the air we can adjourn for the
day I
think I don't think we we have
the we have
the looking for representative wer was
hoping to join us I haven't seen
[Music]
him can you repeat that Madam chair that
that came through very garage when we
were when I sent out my draft amendment
to House Bill
417 I got a question on the nature of
the fiscal committee
involvement and I thought the best thing
to do would be to get some information
from someone who's been on fiscal
representative wer volunteered to join
us and I've been looking for him but I
haven't seen
him
so there is there's a phone call
somebody there's a telephone number in
the
attendees all
right what's the last digit represent
wer please raise your hand if you're
there like the phone got on so let's
just see here he is hello hello there
you are all right yeah I've spent 20
minutes searching for the link that I
was supposed to get to this meeting and
I never found
it I apologize
for not making it easy for that's all
right since you're doing us a
favor so
yes the reason I asked you to join us is
that we have a number of the
emergency order the bills on affecting
emergency orders and states of
emergency and we were concerned about
the role of the fiscal committee and
thought that you would be the best
person to help us with
that well thank you um when the governor
first put in his emergency order last uh
last year and we expected to see
something at fiscal and and we did not
and supposedly we were told well that
it's not required and then it went to
court because um Democrats in one of
them and and three others from the
Democrat leadership sued the governor
and it went to court and the the court
decided in favor of the the governor so
it kind of left it all up in the air
because I had read some of the emergency
things as well which said after so many
days he had to come to fiscal to get our
approval so I wondered why what was
different about this and I never got a
good explanation so I sorry I can't help
you much but that was the only time that
we would have had an opportunity one
would have thought and nothing came to
us well it did not
subsequently doesn't I'm I'm not a
lawyer but when I looked at the
emergency statute not
in the
um under I yeah under the department of
safety the emergency
orders there is note that says that the
F federal government or any federal
agency offers to the state Services
equipment supplies material or fund
for the purposes of Emergency Management
the state acting through the
governor May accept such
offer and when I read the statute on the
fiscal
committee it says that if a grant or
whatever has been is required to be
approved by governor and councel it has
to go through fiscal
this didn't say governor and
Council yeah so I suppose he could say
his executive power and I believe that's
what he won the case on that it was
within his executive power although
normally if it if it's a big a transfer
it could be they would have to come to
fiscal to get the approval of of the uh
rece to receive the money and unusually
usually fiscal approves before it goes
to Governor counsel and then I had a
call from my counselor saying well we're
hearing this and it's coming to you next
and I thought I thought we heard it
first and I inquired into why we hadn't
heard it first and the excuse I got was
well they meet twice a month and you
only meet once a month and I thought
what does that have to do with anything
but sometimes you get some explanations
that don't amount to anything and that
was one okay but if
I if I understand the role of the
council they accept gifts and
grants or at least their uh their not
their minutes are always full of gifts
of Grants and stuff
does there's a a grant if it doesn't
involve a
transfer um we yeah we we approve most
of the
transfers and that's a big part of our
of our agenda and and we also accept
grants and usually the grants do come to
us first but it's part of their job plus
they do contracts which we don't do and
they approve appointments they approve
appointments which don't come to us you
know promoting somebody to major in the
in the National Guard or appointing
someone for a board the plumbers board
that'll come through them but we never
see those things but normally the grants
come through both of
them okay so that the normal procedures
of a grant goes through both fiscal and
ex excutive
Council pretty much most of them
actually go through both of them all
right and how
uh how responsive is
it well we we only we only meet once a
month we have sometimes 40 50 items on
the agenda uh sometimes fiscal has
hundred and something on their agenda
because of all the little appointments
that they have to look at we don't have
to so all those things are going on
continuously and so you know how
responsive you
know I i' I've taken uh things late
requests to the to the agenda the same
day and and put them on the agenda but
um you know
normally the agenda is made up a week or
so in advance and because I have to get
get it to everybody and the members so
they can read what's what's coming and
look at the details and ask any
questions that they would like to have
beforehand so yeah responsive uh you
want to you want to have some heads up
on what's coming but still the meeting
is set like once when we meet the
previous month we set the next month's
meeting once in a while we've had
special
meeting but normally it's not very
responsive if you got to if you just
missed the last meeting and youve got to
wait a month till the next one so yeah
the meantime a lot of things can
happen all right well thank you that's
very abuseful representative
Goen thank you madam chair and as as I
look at this and thank you represent wer
for joining
us my pleasure couple quick questions
and I look at um when we talk about the
emergency orders in the spending of
gifts grants and Loans is
under 21p Co and 43 and that just gives
the governor the ability to spend that
we were talking about um represent wer
would if be wise to include um the
language it's in 124 colon 4 which deals
with applications for an administrative
of Federal Aid uh the language that all
such monies in excess of $50,000 made
available after designation by Governor
Council may be expended by the proper
persons or agencies in the state
government only with the prior approval
of the joint fiscal committee with that
is that is that are you suggesting
language representative go you would
like to add would that be you think that
would be appropriate that way there's a
check on the that way the governor does
have to go before fiscal if it's more
than $50,000 being
appropriated in
Grants well if if this argument is I've
got to start on this
tomorrow then you know it's going to be
a day or two before I can get the fiscal
committee together and all that kind of
thing so there would be delays and it
could be as much as a month as I said so
if if if lot talking about things that
need to be done immediately uh we got a
hurricane tearing up the uh power lines
we got something going wrong and and
there are things he has to react
immediately and and the roads are close
so how do we get to concerete to have a
meeting you know this kind of thing um
so in the at the risk of slowing things
down how much do we want to tie people's
hands to react immediately to an
emergency and that's what it comes down
to I get and a followup if I may follow
up but and when we're talking an
emergency we we can to declare the state
of emergency and I guess my question
would be uh federal dollars and grants
wouldn't be coming in immediately we'd
have to apply for a federal emergency so
we would have time to work on that end
of it wouldn't we yeah quite often we go
in and we've seen SE seen things come
through um fiscal that are two years old
like some of the snowstorms and some of
the the floods we've had you you begin
working on it right away you use you use
your you know you use whatever you have
in your department to fix the road or or
stop the flood or whatever and then that
becomes a soft match for the the Federal
grant which would say we'll take care of
75% so what have you spent so fire and
you said well you we spent $30,000 to do
this this and this okay that's that's
your soft match then they'll probably
give you three times that so yes you're
right some sometimes you gota you got to
react with whatever is available
immediately and then the other the other
details of where the fun is coming from
and who's approved and what's it's
reviewed can come far later and and
we've we've accepted things that were
two years later because it took some of
the towns and cities two years to figure
out all the money they had spent on a
certain thing and and sometimes they
borrowed stuff and then they went back
and rep paid it and so that's yeah it it
took them a couple years to get the
final
accounting thank you
repres thank you madam chair and thank
you representative wer for being here
with us
today uh gener we're not talking about
small dollars here and we're looking at
some sort of disaster issue or some sort
of
Declaration involving you know Federal
reimbursement would it be possible then
to to kind of meet Both Worlds here
perhaps and say okay well that you know
instead of this being a $50,000 Mark
when it comes to some sort of disaster
we could make that a $2 million Mark
where it would allow the state
government to put some things in place
immediately and still deal with the fact
that you know we when we're talking
reimbursement at the federal level of
substantial money that the the check of
going to disc and all that could still
also occur at the same
time well as I said sometimes it took
two years to figure out exactly what did
what did you expend and get everything
together so if if you try to set a a
level it would be hard to know when you
when you achieve that level you
meanwhile you got people rushing around
and got equipment borrowed from here and
there and people running to help you and
then later on somebody somebody had to
keep track of all this and that doesn't
always happen so sometimes following it
up and making inquiries months later and
say did you come into to this did you
bring that did you do this and so it's
it takes a long time to figure out well
exactly how much did we spend on that
thing the first 48 hours and most of the
people are still recovering and and
looking for places to bring the stuff
and all this kind of thing so it it gets
very difficult when you're in the midst
of something to figure out exactly how
much you had unless you had a pretty
good idea in some places that have
um and we've had funds come in lots of
times for disaster preparedness and the
thing to do would be here's here's how
much we got here's here's where these
kits are stored here's what this costs
here's what this costs here's what this
vehicle cost per hour blah blah blah you
had all those things ready that's the
idea of of disaster preparedness if you
know what it's going to cost if you know
what all you know to use this kit
whatever it is and you have things in
kits uh and you have sandbags that
you're going to fill up and all this of
think and you have a supply of them so
if you if you know that stuff and you've
done a good job on disaster preparedness
you could come up probably within a week
of how much you really did expend but to
to set a a limit even if it's $10
million if it's going on across a whole
County you got to do a lot of
communication which people are not ready
to do in the middle of that so it's it's
a tough area no matter how you get into
it representative
wer I'm not very familiar with Emergency
Management do I understand correctly
that the main issue is that the federal
government requires matching funds and
we have to document said matching
funds that is that is a big issue I was
in Emergency Management in the Air Force
Reserve and yes they they wanted they
wanted everything to accounted for and
want to know exactly what happened now
this if this equipment got destroyed or
whatever and and that was one of the
biggest things in Emergency Management
in a state they you had to reach a
certain level before the feds would come
in and so you had to some of the people
in the in the uh Emergency Management
were basically Bean counters and they're
just keeping track and as they're
dispatching things they said okay call
this one call that one write this down
write that down somebody had to keep
track because when you went to this to
the feds they wanted to know exactly and
I remember one time back when I was in
the Air Force and reserve and they had a
disaster in North Carolina and because
the uh the head of the Emergency
Management was the wrong party when the
new governor got in he didn't replace
that person so when they had these
Coastal storms that tore everything up
it was weeks before they even responded
or even even know what they had because
they kind of destroyed Emergency
Management and so it there were months
in recovery lot longer than they should
have been because they didn't have
someone keeping track of all these
little noise that go on when you're
recovering from an emergency so and
those people would also be the ones that
would be have assessments they'd have or
even been involved with a Civil Air
Patrol If the weather wasn't too
terrible to overfly and take pictures uh
he had to coordinate with the Air Force
to get them so all these sorts of things
were going on um in in in an emergency
and someone had to be reporting exactly
what happened exactly how much and and
the way they started off and one lecture
I went to is okay if your roof Falls in
that's your problem call your insurance
company if every roof on your street
gets ripped off by a downburst well call
the the city and see if they can help or
if it's if it goes across the city line
call the county see what they can do and
you finally got to the state but if it's
widespread enough and then they finally
went to the feds if it was exceeded
their capacity so there were a lot of
levels that I was involved in at various
times in in disaster clearness and and
how you would recover from it and there
was a lot of cleanup numbers that had to
go into and somebody had to be
responsible for keeping track of all
this and so you that's what Emergency
Management people were supposed to be
ready to
do thank you there's a lot of Reliance
on on having a good
organization I'm sure uh representative
goalie is familiar with a lot of
this yes representative BR you had a
question I do thank you madam chair
thank you representative
wer but we we know what
the um hurdles are in trying to assess
this and that could be taken into
consideration is that right Ian we could
take that into
consideration and asking for some
oversight so it's not something
that's
unattainable no
but whether that person is ready and has
the likely uh figures and you know
that's what we hope Emergency Management
would be ready to do and they would have
uh you know maybe get up satellite
images and all this kind of thing that
to uh answer the call and see what what
damages you had and maybe get them
almost on real
time and we' got a lot better capacity
than we used to have for that
so thankfully I'm thankful for that
thank you very
much represent leus um thank you madam
chair from what I heard it sounds like
uh the issue of a delay of a week or or
even maybe as much as a month in
approving receiving let's say Federal
disaster money even in this Co
situation it wasn't likely that it would
be a huge problem because it would take
some time to uh even figure out what
you're spending and how
much is that true
true
than on
valro thank you I'm sorry I think I
might have lost the string of the
conversation but um so this might be a
naive question but if we're talking
about being in the midst of an emergency
in my experience when there's an
emergency everything gets dropped and so
questions about whether it has to wait
two weeks or the next time the fiscal
committee meets is moved uh the governor
can react and he can
communicate with his advisory team and
staff and I'm I'm sorry I'm just a
little confused why can't the fiscal
committee come together and react to the
emergency within a
reasonable period of time if I'm
mistaken please forgive me
um because I I think it's partly due to
its nature and partly because it's it
sounds like its activities are
not the start of the process they're the
end of the process is what it sounds
like to me they're doing cleanup is that
correct representative wler yes what
what we're talking talking about is the
fiscal committee will approve some
disaster uh assistance but at that point
the disaster is over by that time and
and the people that are trying to figure
out exactly what it cost so until all
that takes place you don't even need the
fiscal committee you know the the
governor can grab whatever he has to he
he can call up the National
Guard at his at his order without going
to the federal government and getting
them to pay for it he can ask them to
pay lat but he can he's got a lot of
Manpower he can put his finger on
immediately whereas all this other stuff
this is after the after the fact and
after the numbers are all in so it's not
so much that the fiscal committee has to
even be involved early on thank thank
you that's very very good to
know my
pleasure all right it's reached it's
reached our usual point of lack of
Interest
we're fully informed fully informed ah
thank you yes all right I'm glad to get
in on this I didn't realize there was
going to be an emergency management but
I got to use my eight years experience
in the Air Force Reserve for that so yes
thank you very much information we appr
representative goalie no Madam chair I
just want
to ask the question one more time of
Representative wer does he feel that
fiscal should have somewhat the
oversight of how this money is spent or
do he feel comfortable just letting the
governor spend it as he
feels I guess I would answer you that
you know I don't think that the um
fiscal committee needs to get involved
unless it's a very longterm thing like
some of this pandemic stuff went over
months so yes at some point we should
have some ability to meet but if it's if
it's something that's taken care of
within a week or two or a month it's not
so important to get the fiscal committee
but if if the fiscal committee is going
to meet anyway then you ought to you
ought to put it on the agenda so we can
all be involved because you know you
hate to you hate to run off into a
policymaking area without getting into
the policymaking branch of government
which is the legislature so if you're if
you're just responding with a action
plan that's one thing but if you're
trying to make new policy then
definitely the legislature should be
involved I think we can all agree to
that yeah it's where we draw the
line there's because when there's tens
of millions of dollars coming in over a
long period of time I feel you should
have a say fiscal should at least be re
yes because because now it you you don't
have the excuse of it's it's an
emergency if it's going over a long
period of time emergency was over pretty
early and and now it's all planning and
and preparation and carrying out a plan
and there better be a plan so thank you
you know you know that you work with
plan yes we do all right representative
you got a question or
comment um yeah I just had one question
because it seems to me that some of the
federal money for emergency management
is prescribed so it's prescribed when
when we have the flood you know when
you're getting the emergency Grant from
the federal government you don't
actually get the money you get a an
agreement to reimburse you for expenses
up to a certain amount and you know what
those expenses are they're you know Road
repair and that kind of stuff in this
pandemic situation we had some of the
money was very different because it went
to the
state and the
governor was able to make decisions
about about how to spend that money you
know he could you know he could allocate
it for small businesses or he could
allocate it for nonprofits or you know I
don't know the degree but he had a lot
of discretion so it seems that those
discretionary type situations are when
fiscal should be involved you know you
don't you don't have to ask fiscal about
reimbursement for the road repairs to
the municipalities but there are and I
just don't know what how do you describe
those kinds of expenditures that should
go to
fiscal well if it's a health emergency
there's a there's another whole section
of law under the uh Commissioner of
Health and Human Services with her her
Rea her right now it's a her her
reaction to to what took place and which
parts of Public Health and so on which
division she called out in public health
so there's a bunch of those things that
are already in in in the law saying how
that person supposed to react so and and
when it's it's roads you got Department
of Transportation when it's in the fire
department and police department get
called out in every emergency like that
as well so all these different agencies
have plans for the various types of
things that go on and their their job is
to react immediately and someone has to
keep track of what they did so the
grants don't come in all that quickly
during the emergency but when they when
it's a long-term thing like a pandemic
then you do have an opportunity to go
back to the legislature and go back to
the fiscal committee and and get some
approval so that we're all on board and
we all know what's going on so thank you
as I say you
know it's it's the immediate reaction
that you don't need the approval for you
better have a
plan
anything else thank
you representative Wilder I do
appreciate your your efforts to join
us thank you did take some effort all
right uh chairman Maguire glad to help
hope I was
helpful we feel much better
informed thank you bye
now any
other questions
comments
oh you're brief um all this talk about
disaster reminds me that I wanted to
talk to representative short we
factiously talked about a bill that we
might sponsor honoring a or dishonoring
a certain Intrepid Explorer I presented
that and tried to do some education at
my committee meeting and my reaction
well let me describe it this way it was
kind of like run for your
life it's not well
received thank you that's
itan if you will be very brief okay
um I won't say anything about HB 155
there there'll probably be some blur
action on it um at the end of the day
session in April I was going to say my
perception just I don't know as much
about as Rend Wilder did because I've
never served on the fiscal committee
even on finance is that they were one of
several bodies which uh had authority
over what to do with the pandemic
funding and were kind of shut out of the
process I it also happened to Executive
Council and even I think the legislature
we P one of the bill many bills that
governor vetoed was uh amended you know
after March 13th to deal with pandemic
issues and I think part of the reason
for that V was that uh it was out of our
jurisdiction because it was you know
pandemic money we were talking about so
I I the government made a political
decision not to involve especially joint
fiscal and the executive Council and U
he got away with it and I mean what he's
done has been fairly successful but
that's uh it could have been done
differently though and it probably
should be done differently going forward
that's yes thank you for your red
side as for the Columbus Day um we'll
probably be hearing about in April but
don't worry about it now thank
you no one else has anything I think the
committee will adjourn for the day we
are meeting next Monday
for ah we're doing a joint meeting with
Commerce on the audit of the Liquor
Commission and we also have have a short
meeting in the afternoon a public
hearing on a Senate
bill that's a very tiny Omnibus it has
three sections and one of them is solar
eclipse day which we which I've been
asked to bring forward quickly we should
be able to hear and exec that build on
Monday thank you all and I appreciate
all the the careful thought that went
into considering this
amendment um I have a question did
anybody get the printed copy of the um
liquor audit yet I have I got one I have
ordered one for you and one for
representative leus who also asked for
it and one spare just in case somebody
realizes they want one later on it has
not yet been delivered to the
lob but it it I've asked for
it will mine be
mailed
uh I will ask I if I get when I get it I
will have it mailed to you oh okay thank
you and for mine if you let me know it's
in the other representative lus will be
up here later in the week
and
right have a good
weekend than